Hey Kean! Hey Hendrik! Hey Steiger! Hey Kean! Hey Hendrik! Hey Steiger!
Hey!
Haben wir jetzt alle Kombinationen durch?
Äh, ja. Hey Hendrik.
Hab ich schon gesagt.
Hey Kean!
Verdammt.
Okay.
Hey Steiger!
Hey Kean! Hey Hendrik!
Ich durchbreche mal wieder die vierte Wand.
Hi Zuhörer, willkommen bei Podcast Akronomisierbar Folge...
Drei.
Yay, drei Folgen.
Vier Folgen.
Oh Gott.
wir haben quasi die
Nullnummer direkt übersprungen und machen
einfach einen
nullindizierten Podcast
und die Nullnummer war direkt
eine richtige Folge, spontan
aus der Kalten rausgestartet
gleich richtig gepodcastet
ja wir nehmen diesmal
ausnahmsweise nicht früh morgens auf wie das letzte Mal
was war's
morgens?
guten Morgen
Kehran. Ich kann mich nicht mehr
erinnern, welche Uhrzeit das war.
Sicher, dass es nicht abends war?
Das spielt eh keine Rolle.
Früh morgens. Naja, jetzt nehmen wir ja auch
gerade früh morgens an.
Ein Podcast spielt keine Rolle.
Aber ich finde es eigentlich ganz cool, wenn die Podcaster sagen,
wann diese Folge aufgenommen wurde, dann hat man
auch ein bisschen Bezug
als Zuhörer zu den Themen,
die die Leute referenzieren. Ob das jetzt schon
hornealt ist, weil
akronomisierbar kann man ja noch in 500 Jahren hören.
Hören auf jeden Fall.
Also wir haben akronomisierbar Folge 3 und heute ist der 2. April 2017.
21.14 Uhr.
Ach stimmt, tatsächlich. Weißt du, was das heißt?
Dass wir heute sehr ernst sind.
Weil nämlich der 1. April vorbei ist.
Ja, so ist es.
Die ganzen Witze sind durch. Habt ihr auch irgendwelche coolen April-Scherze mitbekommen?
Ich habe am 31. März
in der Stadt
auf Shopping-Tour
und habe mal kurz geschaut nach einem bestimmten Laden,
ob ich den bei Google Maps finde.
Plötzlich war da ein sehr interessant gefärbter Button.
Dann habe ich auf der Prager Straße in Dresden
Miss Pac-Man spielen können.
War es wieder da?
Ja, aber ich war sehr verwirrt, weil es war nicht der 1. April.
Aber ich meine,
aus drei war es dem Zeitpunkt bestimmt schon der 1. April.
Also ich konnte das vorher noch spielen.
Aber witzigerweise
der Kater bist, sondern springt irgendwo anders hin.
Du warst genau dort, wo ich war.
Man konnte es auswählen. Ich kenne es nur von
letztem Jahr und da konnte man halt
irgendwas auswählen und Pac-Man
spielen. Nach Google geht also so ein bisschen die
Kreativität aus. Das ist jetzt schon ein Reoccurring
April. Sie haben ja noch einen anderen gehabt.
Es gab ja noch den Google Gnome.
Das Google Home für den
Smart Yard.
Wie? Das ist ein smarter
Gartenzwerg gewesen.
Den stellst du dir in deinen Yard und
dann kannst du den fragen, wie das Wetter ist. Und dann sagt er dir,
ist sonnig und dann kannst du hochschauen und sagen, oh, es stimmt.
Das ist super geil.
Und der kann deinen Gartenschlauch an und aus machen.
Und mir sind die Google-Aprilscherze super
eigentlich am begeistern gewesen. Ich hätte mir dieses,
ich weiß nicht, ob sie das wirklich implementiert haben,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, für das Video, was sie drüber gemacht haben,
haben sie es mal eben implementiert.
Die Google-Android-Tastatur, mit der man
Morse-Code tippt, wodurch du nur noch
zwei Tasten brauchst,
was es mega usable
macht. Also du hast nur noch eine Taste
für lang und eine Taste für kurz und dann tippst
du Morse-Code. Ich meine,
Implementieren kannst du... Haben sie das sogar implementiert gehabt?
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen,
weil Android-Tastaturen sind sehr
vielseitig. Also ich habe mal
in meiner kurzen Android-Zeit mal
so eine fantastische Tastatur mit 8-Pen genutzt.
Da hast du so Kreise gedreht, statt zu tippen.
Und je nachdem, wie die Struktur dieses Kreises
war, hat er halt Buchstaben rausgemacht.
War auch ein bisschen Zeit, bevor man da reingekommen ist, aber es war
mega geil. Krass. Also die Leute
sagen mir immer, das sieht mega witzig aus, wenn ich auf
meiner Tastatur swipe. Hast du so ein
Swiftkey-Nutzer, wisst du? Ne, es ist nicht Swiftkey.
Das geht mir da ganz normal in Android.
Ich finde das super geil.
Also entweder du verkackst ein ganzes Wort,
dann schicke ich den Leuten manchmal einfach falsche Wörter.
Die sind dann halt richtig getippt, aber es sind halt komplett falsche Wörter.
Manchmal. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin ziemlich oft bullscht.
Vielleicht soll man da mal so ein Best-of aus meinen
wohlsten Nachrichten rausschreiben.
Typos. Best-of.
Ja, ansonsten, ich habe als ASCII
Twitter-Account gepostet, dass wir
einen kleinen Wasserschaden hatten.
Und das dementsprechend ab jetzt der Kaffee
2,50 Euro, die Marta auch kostet.
bis wir die Kosten für die Reparaturen wieder rein haben.
Also alle, die das jetzt hören und die sich erschrocken haben,
Aski wird es natürlich nicht.
Ist das auch ein Reused-April-Scherz
vom letzten Jahr?
Nee, ich glaube, letztes Jahr hatte ich gepostet,
dass wir Kolle-Mate abschaffen, weil die nicht 100% vegan ist.
Stimmt, vegan hast du ja mal gepostet.
Irgendwann warst du mal, dass
so Aski intern, dass irgendwer die Fenster
offen gelassen hat und reingeregt hat,
das war eine ganze Kunst im Arsch.
Und da bin ich mega drauf reingefallen,
weil ich halt der Letzte war am Vorabend, der da war
und ich bin mir richtig fucking schuldig gefühlt.
Nee, das hat der Robert letztes Jahr gepostet, stimmt,
dass es reingeregnet hat. Wir haben
oben so Fenster unter der Decke
und unten drunter
hängen Bilder und da könnte man
sich vorstellen, dass es reinregnet.
Was keiner präsentiert ist, dass es mal passiert ist,
dass wir die Fenster offen gelassen haben im Sommer
und Schnecken reingekrochen sind.
Das passiert immer auf dem selber, wo neben dem anderen regnet ist.
Und die klettern dann, also die kriechen
dann an der Wand lang runter.
Und dann sieht man so eine Schleimspur
und einmal ist eine Stecke
ganz eiskalt über so ein Bild gekrochen.
Das war ein bisschen mit, weil das war halt in der Ölgemälde.
Das ist unschön.
Aber ansonsten gab es im Internet eigentlich ein paar coole Sachen.
Was ich besonders gemein fand, wo ich tatsächlich auch drauf reingefallen bin,
ist, dass die Rick and Morty-Macher getweetet haben,
dass die neue Staffel anfängt, gestern Abend,
Staffel 3, Folge 1 aired.
Ich bin drauf, ja, hier, zeig mir, wo geht's.
Ich höre immer noch, das weiß ich schon seit Monaten,
Rick and Morty Staffel 3 schon läuft.
Nee, die ist noch to be announced.
Immer noch.
Kurzer Einwurf an der Stelle während des
Schnitts der Folge. Tatsache, dass
die Folge nicht da ist, war
auch ein April-Scherz. Die neue Folge
Rick and Morty ist tatsächlich da
und sie ist verdammt gut.
Schaut sie euch an.
Also ich habe gehört, dass Swift sich umbenennt.
Und ich bin auch
immer noch nicht ganz sicher, ob es nicht stimmt, weil es gibt
diesen Instant Messenger,
diese Jabber Library, Swift,
und die haben die Webseite Swift.im,
also wie in Semester. Ich dachte, die waren
Messe in Client statt in Library. Das ist ein
Swift,
Swift ist der
Jabber Client, und die haben dann noch eine
Java und eine C++ Library,
und die haben sich,
die hatten halt Probleme, weil sie
auch gleichzeitig die gleichen Versionen rausgebracht
haben, wie die Sprache. Also es gab plötzlich Swift
3.0, und die haben dann
über das Feature geschrieben, und ich dachte mir, krass,
was die in die Standardbibliothek schon alles einbauen.
und die
anderen Libraries hießen irgendwie Swifton
und so weiter
und zwar alles irgendwie daran angelehnt, also die C++
Library und die Java Library und jetzt haben sie hier
Swift is changing due to
potential confusion between Swift
XMPP Client and
Apple's Swift
Programming Language
we're adopting a new name
for Swift. Also nicht
Swift ändert sich, sondern
Swift ändert sich.
was noch witzig ist, also wir hatten
die Sektion schon Things Called Swift.
Ich meine, wir hatten tatsächlich...
Swift ist ja nicht mal die erste Programmiersprache, die Swift heißt.
Swift, the parallel programming language.
Swift 4, also der
XMPP-Client, heißt...
Aber Swift 4 kommt auch weiter.
Das wird halt nicht so heißen. Heißt dann angeblich
Jolly Brisk.
Wir haben dann kein Logo mehr mit einer Schweife, sondern
so ein englischer Typ mit einem Regenschirm ist das Logo.
Aber wie geil! Und die Libraries
dazu heißen, die C++
Library heißt, also das heißt übrigens
Jolly Brisk TM.
Ich glaube, Teil von dem Trademark
ist TM. Die Library
C++ Library heißt
Splendid.
Die Java Library heißt
Super.
Und dann gab es irgendwie
Swift Library.
Das Hauptmenü von der Seite ist
Jolly Brisk. Das leitet aber glaube ich
weiter zu Swift IM
slash Swift HTML. Also das ist glaube ich wirklich
ein Scherz. Splendid
weiter auf die alte Swifton Library.
Super auf die
Swifton Java Library. Und dann gibt es noch
What How ist die
About-Seite.
Der Blog heißt Sorry.
Sorry. Und Support
heißt Excuse Me.
Sehr schön.
Das ist echt gut.
Ich meine, es ist gemein, wenn du ein Projekt hast,
was du von Haus aus schon schlecht googelbar ist.
Dann kommt Apple daher und schmeißt einfach so ein Monster
hin. Und dann plötzlich findet dich niemand
Never Again. Ich war am Freitag spontan
Konzert, 5 Euro Konzert, im Beatpool
einer Band namens Golf.
Die Band ist super,
also ich muss sagen, es war ein ziemlich
geiles Konzert. Ich hatte ein bisschen Angst,
dass es zu voll wird, es waren 50 Leute da.
Ich war auch nur einmal im Beatpool, da waren
nur so 30, 40 Leute da. Ich gehe am nächsten Freitag
wieder zu einem Konzert, ich erwarte da 600 Leute,
weil wir da schon vor 3 Monaten
die Karten für 25 Euro gekauft haben.
Es war einfach bloß, die haben ein bisschen,
also Stage-Typen war leider nicht.
Also das eine war, wo ich da war,
sind alle gegangen, nachdem die tatsächlich Band kamen.
wenn nur für die Vorband da waren.
Echt?
Die sind zwar ein bisschen traurig.
Gegen die man schlecht googeln kann.
Dann gab es noch andere April-Scherze,
wollen wir die irgendwie mal zusammentragen?
Ja, ich habe mich mal kurz umgeschaut bei den RFCs,
weil das auch immer ein ergebliches Thema ist.
Es gibt tatsächlich drei Einreichungen.
Die erste
macht so ein bisschen Algebra mit IPv6-Adressen
und ich glaube, der Aufhänger
war Floating IP-Adresses
in IPv6,
die eigentlich dafür da sind,
dass man ein mobiles Gerät mit einer
mehr oder weniger festen Adresse versehen kann
und irgendwie ein Gerät, was sich dann Home Agent
nennt, die Daten weiterleitet,
sodass man halt ständig verbunden ist.
Es gibt wirklich so einen Standard, den irgendwie
Apple für
Siri implementiert hat.
Nee, das ist nicht TCP Multipath,
das ist eine andere Angelegenheit.
Dort geht es wirklich darum, um diese
Floating-IP-Adresses und
die Leute fanden es einfach witzig, weil
Float ja im Programmieren
die Fließkummerzahl ist.
und meinten, okay, dann können wir
darauf aufbauen und teilen einfach die 128-Bit-IPv6-Adresse
in den 64-Bit-Reellen-Teilen
und in den 64-Bit-Imaginären-Teilen.
Da gibt es imaginary IP-Adresses.
Genau, es gibt auch mehr.
Es gibt Prim, die Darstellung
einer IP-Adresse als komplette ganze Zahl,
als Integer, weil man es einfach direkt aufmultipliziert.
Da kannst du durch Faktorisierung irgendwie.
Ja, richtig.
Es gibt Palindrom-Adressen,
die von hinten hier von vorn als ganze Zahl gleich gelesen werden können.
Ich glaube, die sind schnell vergeben.
Und es gibt tatsächlich auch quadratische IP-Adressen.
Und ein DNS-Root-Server kann dann auch die Wurzel daraus ziehen.
Deswegen kann auch absolut jeder ein DNS-Root-Server betreiben,
der einfach die Wurzel aus quadratischen IP-Adressen ziehen kann.
Square Root.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich kurz durch RFC hier durchscrolle,
ich meine, typisch ist es ja etliche Seiten Text hier, 16,
um genau zu sein.
Ich würde tatsächlich nicht kurz beim Überfliegen
dem Objekt vorne checken,
dass es dann sein Abflugschirm hat.
Das klingt so.
Ja, ich meine, es ist eine interessante Problematik
und es ist eine interessante Idee dafür,
aber sicherlich haben sich Leute,
die bedeuten, kleinfach das und sich darüber Gedanken gemacht,
der meint, dass das sinnvoll ist.
Aber hier davon steht oben in der Ecke Besserwisser Networks.
Ja, das checkst du wahrscheinlich eher,
wenn du Requeo-Messiger mal RFCs liest.
Was ich schön finde, sind die
X-EPs, die Erweiterung zu Jabber,
zu dem XMPP-Protokoll, da hast du
irgendwie so eine Tabelle mit allen XEPs,
irgendwie XEP 0001 bis
XEP
0390, also schon bei
390 und da steht dann irgendwie
als Type Procedural, Standard
Track, Historical,
Draft und so weiter
und bei manchen steht tatsächlich
dahinter Humorous, weil
jedes Jahr irgendwie als
so was weiß ich.
Sehr rücksichtsvoll. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, dass jemand wirklich für
nimmt? Naja, das ist kein Problem.
Vielleicht schreiben Sie das erst nachträglich.
Dass es halt da bleibt.
Das gibt irgendwie
Presence obtained via kinetic extension.
Poke.
Oder
irgendwann hat mal einer geschrieben,
ja, Jabber ist ja
XML basiert. Das ist ein bisschen altbacken.
Ich schlage vor, dass mir das alles auf
JSON basiert.
Es gibt ein XDP, das heißt
XMPP
Everything
via PubSub,
ein bisschen sinnlos,
und Binary XMPP.
Die sind alle nicht so witzig, wenn ich
die FBusilamen vorlese.
Ja, da müsste man sich, glaube ich, ein bisschen
einarbeiten. Also ich habe auch ein bisschen Zeit gebraucht
für
das letzte RFC aus diesem Jahr,
April RFC.
840?
840, genau.
Und da sind einfach ein paar sehr liebevolle
ASCII-Darstellungen von diversen
Schlagworten, die man so kennt,
so Generic Security Mechanism,
zum Beispiel.
Oder das mit den NEN-Carriers.
Oder a fine mirror showing the reflection
of a vampire bat.
Yep.
Davon nur ein Rechteck.
Ja, kann man sich mal durch.
Kann man sich mal durch.
Der RFC heißt
The Art of Ascii,
or a true and accurate representation
of a menagerie of things fabulous
and wonderful in the form of character.
Es gab auch ein paar
April-Schätze, die einfach nur geschrieben haben,
wir hören jetzt auf mit C++ oder C
und wir schneiden jetzt unsere Software komplett.
War es nicht Tor irgendwas?
Da habe ich geguckt, bei Tor hieß es,
es wäre mal sinnvoll, wenn wir mal von C wegkommen.
Und deswegen machen wir jetzt Rust.
Aber das ist ernst gemeint.
Das war am 31.
Es gab auch schon länger geplant.
Das war am 31.03.
Es gab mal den Entwickler von Tomboy,
dieser Gnome-Notiz-App,
der gesagt hat, ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf C Sharp und Mono,
ich schreibe das Ding jetzt komplett in C++ neu.
Das war am 1. April und alle so
drei Wochen später fertig.
Ihr habt das Ding jetzt.
Und das gibt es jetzt beides.
Dummerweise.
Ich wäre ja mal dafür, dass diese April-Scherz-Dinger
mal nach UTC bekannt gegeben werden sollen.
Damit es da keine
mehr Sicherheit gibt.
Es ist immer super confusing, wenn irgendein Australier
oder Asiate so ein April-Scherz raushaut
und alle sich so denken, das war doch am 31.
Wir sind alle in dem Kontext.
Ja, das ist schwierig.
Beide Leute haben gepostet,
Also, wir wollen Wayland nicht mehr
ein C machen.
In einer sicheren Sprache.
Also Rust oder...
Und dann schreiben sie aber Go und das ist der Prilscherz.
Rust oder wie meinst du ernst?
Haskell.
Und witzigerweise hat aber der Typ, der das gepostet hat,
hat schon seit Wochen an der Haskell-Lagree
für Dings gearbeitet.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob wie ernst das ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist er, also wenn er nicht
deswegen auf diese Idee kam,
hat er sicherlich nicht Wayland neu implementiert
in Haskell, oder?
Nee, aber das
Wayland-Protokoll.
Ach so, okay.
Wayland ist ja ein kleines Server-Protokoll.
Es gibt auch eine relative
Rust-Implementierung von Wayland
already. Mein Satzbau ist schon
englisch fürchterlich.
Und der hat das halt komplett einmal in Haskell gebaut.
Das kann man ja durchaus machen.
Die Torleute hatten ja tatsächlich schon länger geplant,
diese Unterhaltung, die da am 31.3. stattfand,
wo es darum ging, was machen wir mit der Zukunft
und was wären da vielleicht sinnvoller
als Entwicklung. Und haben da ja auch über Rust gesprochen
und irgendwer hatte halt
einen Post geschrieben auf Hacker News, wo es drum ging,
dass da Go-By rauskam und das war dann
die April-Scherz-Abwandlung davon.
Wir haben jetzt
gerade 15 Minuten rum, das war der erste
Go-Rant des 8.
Ich habe nicht immer Go-Rantet, ich versuche nicht mehr
über Sprachen zu ranten, habe ich mir vorgenommen.
Ich versuche, wenn dann
sinnvoll fundierte Aussagen zu treffen.
Und meistens Dinge liebt zu haben.
Irgendjemand hat mal, nachdem
immer wieder ein Voren aufkommt,
Eigentlich wäre es schön, wenn man das mal in einer sicheren Sprache
mittlerweile neu schreibt, weil es ja kritische Infrastruktur ist.
Und dann sagt irgendjemand Rust
und die Leute, die dann C++-Gurus
sind und das schon seit 20 Jahren
machen, sagen dann, lass mich doch in Ruhe.
Die reden jetzt mittlerweile schon von einer
Rust Evangelism Strike Force.
Hast du den Rust-Subreddit gestern auch gemacht?
Und es gibt ein...
So sah der Rust-Subreddit gestern aus.
Oben fettes Logo von der Rust Evangelism Strike Force.
Genau, da gab es jetzt auch einen Twitter-Account, der sieht super aus.
Pack mal einen Screenshot, bitte in die Show Notes,
wenn ich es nicht vergesse. Das ist eigentlich hiermit eine Erinnerung
für mich. Wenn ihr an dieser Stelle
seid, in die Show Notes guckt und da
kein Screenshot... Nein, warte, noch besser. Ich packe
einfach das Logo der Rust Eventless im Strikeforce
für diesen Teil hier als Podcast
Artwork rein. Wenn ein
Klein verschiedener Artworks kann, dann kann das auch. Aber ich packe es
zu dir nochmal in die Show Notes. Wenn ihr an dieser Stelle
angekommen seid und das noch nicht
gesehen habt in den Show Notes, dann schreibt einfach
mal eine Direktnachricht über Twitter an
Kejan Köh. Okay.
Dann schicke ich es euch.
Ich glaube, noch irgendwelche April-Schätze?
Was war denn Harlan Haskins Swift-Jahr?
Harlan Haskins ist ein Typ,
der war intern bei Apple
und hat mit einem Swift-Compiler ein bisschen rumgedoktert.
Unter anderem auch der einzige Swift-Contributor,
der mein Schwal-Projekt gestartet hat.
Ich mag den generell, weil der
sehr viel LLVM-Fu macht und einen coolen Blog hat,
wo der sehr viel über LLVM schreibt
und LLVM-Bindings
in Swift geschrieben hat und
mega viel witzigen Spaß macht.
Und der hat eben
einen Pull Request zu Swift
geöffnet, in Swift Depot,
wo der einen neuen Operator hinzugefügt hat.
Nämlich hat Swift die Möglichkeit,
dass du zum Beispiel so Dinge schreibst wie
if foo is string.
Also falls foo vom Typen String ist,
dann gehst du in den nächsten Block rein.
Und sowas kannst du halt machen.
Und er hat halt den isn't-Operator
vorgeschlagen, falls du halt
checken willst, dass ein bestimmter Typ nicht vorhanden ist.
Und hat das halt nicht nur vorgeschlagen,
sondern auch vollständig implementiert und testgeschrieben.
der PR baut halt auch und das ist
vollständig mit drin. Das ist beeindruckend.
Der Typ hat mega viel Spaß.
Es ist halt genau dieselbe Anzahl an Zeichen,
wie wenn du Ausrufezeichen und in Klammern
irgendwas typisch schreibst.
Also das ist ja nicht das, was von Haus aus geht.
Aber ich finde das mega cool, dass das halt komplett
implementiert hat. Ja, das Syntactic Sugar ist.
Es gibt ja in CoffeeScript gibt es ja
Is und Isn't. Isn't gibt es tatsächlich in CoffeeScript?
Es gibt Isn't in CoffeeScript.
Und es gibt Aliases für Booleans.
Es gibt nicht nur True und False
in CoffeeScript ohne Scheiß. Es gibt auch
yes und no. Für die ganzen Objective-C-Nazis.
Und on und off.
Manchmal ergibt das im Kontext halt Sinn.
Das ist super, weil so ist im Prinzip
das Gegenteil von on
is no.
Das heißt,
du kannst ja in Vim ohne weiteres mal zwei Zeichen
austauschen mit einer Tastikombi.
Das ist sehr, sehr dumm.
Das fördert Bug sehr unglaublich.
Aber es ist super geil, wenn du Config-Dateien
schreibst oder irgendwelche Settings schreibst.
dann liest es sich irgendwie schöner,
wenn du On und Off schreibst.
Prinzipiell ja.
Yes und No ist halt manchmal semantisch einfach schöner.
Prinzipiell stimme ich dir zu,
aber gerade die Kombo aus No und On
macht es halt wirklich ein bisschen schwierig vertretbar,
finde ich.
Du kannst auch Yes und False machen.
Ja, Gott.
Ich meine Objective-C hat ja auch nur Yes und No,
weil sie halt True und False nicht mehr nehmen konnten,
weil es in beiden Schreibweisen halt schon weg war.
Ja, so ein paar von den Designentscheidungen
von Objective-C. Also True Force kleingeschrieben war halt
in C schon drin, sorry.
Und True Force großgeschrieben sind halt
klassen Namen dann gewesen, deshalb konnte ich sagen, sorry.
Also ein paar von den Designentscheidungen
von Objective-C würde ich mir gerne mal
erklären lassen. Gibt sicher gute Erklärungen
für. Die haben die Sprache
nicht hingerotzt wie sonst was, aber sie ist halt
über die Jahre nicht gerade schön geworden.
Wie war das? Die wollten einfach keine
Sachen von C überschreiben, damit sie immer
ein Superset von C bleiben oder sowas?
Ja. Das ist ja Objective-C++.
Ja. Das muss man ja machen.
Das klingt noch esoterischer.
Snapchat?
Ich habe bloß gelesen, ich habe Snapchat nicht installiert,
aber Snapchat hatte wohl einen recht witzigen
April-Scherz,
weil Facebook hasst ja Snapchat
und versucht ja Snapchat kaputt
zu machen, weil sie
Stories einbauen, diese Stories-Featuren
mit dem Snapchat groß geworden sind, sowohl in Instagram
als auch in Facebook, als auch zwischenzeitlich in WhatsApp.
Alle Facebook-Produkte halt.
Um da richtig
Offensive aufzufahren gegenüber Snapchat. Und Snapchat
hatte halt gestern einen Filter drin, ich kann es ja so
Filter machen, wenn du dich selbst in der Selfie-Kamera
siehst, wo du so Filterswipen und so
Hundgesichter hast
und so Bullshit und in einem hast
du halt dann einfach komplett die Instagram-UI
gehabt und es sah halt aus, ob du gerade ein beschissenes
Instagram-Bild hast mit deiner Mutter, hat ein Kommentar
drunter geschrieben und so weiter. Das fand ich einfach witzig.
Das ist ja immer so ganz kurz an einem Tag mal so eine
Gegenoffensive, wir fahren einfach so spaßenshalber so.
Ihr seid auch scheiße.
Verdient.
Ein guter Bekannter hat
auf die Core-YouTools-Mailing-Liste
einen kleinen Patch submitted.
bei dem das LN-Kommando
ab sofort per default symlinks
anstatt hardlinks erzeugt.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Naja, eigentlich nicht.
Default-Behaviour ändern ist überhaupt nicht cool.
Ja, eben.
Das wäre schön, wenn das von Anfang an so gewesen wäre.
Ja, fände ich auch. Das würde ich gerne beschreiben.
Ja.
Aber er hat dann Patch-Dirik geschrieben.
Oh, das ist ja auch nicht gerade wenig Content.
Ja.
In diesem LN-Mailing-Gest-Archiv
fehlt mir natürlich jegliches Syntax-Highlighting.
Aber das ist, ich scrolle hier ein bisschen.
Also wir müssen diese Liste mal aufbauen
und die ganzen URLs noch dann in die Show Notes schreiben.
Es gab vor ein paar Jahren auch immer schöne
von den Linux-Distros
April-Scherze.
Sowas wie Pac-Man,
Arch-Logs-Verheiratet-Pac-Man
jetzt mit System-D
und weil das so viele Vorteile bringt,
haben sie das miteinander verkoppelt.
Das hat allerdings den Nachteil, dass du
wenn du ein Update machst und Software installierst,
musst du dein Betriebssystem mal neu starten.
Und das Krasseste war eigentlich
diese Collab von
Debian, Arch Linux und
Fedora oder Suse, die gesagt haben,
es gibt zu viele
Linux-Distributionen, wir arbeiten
ab jetzt zusammen an der
Canterbury-Distribution und das wird
quasi eine Zusammenführung von
allen drei Distros sein, an der wir jetzt gemeinsam
weiter haben.
Also Fedora bin ich mir nicht sicher,
aber es war definitiv Debian und
Arch dabei.
Ja, war interessant.
Vor allem, weil es gar nicht zusammenpasst so richtig.
Die Debian-Leute sind ja eigentlich immer sehr weit
hinten.
Naja, es stimmt eigentlich nicht.
Was bei denen als Stable zählt.
Sie werden ridiculed, dafür hinterher zu sein.
Weil Debian-Testing
halt gerade so rankommt an
das, was andere als
Alt und Stable. Ja, und da haut es manchmal auch quer.
Genau. Und Arch Linux ist ja
komplett auf der anderen Seite.
Das ist halt echt
wie jetzt fix für diesen Bugner.
zieht ihr die neue Version von der Software.
Genau.
Es gibt noch keinen Ersatz für Gnome 2,
weil Gnome 3 rausgekommen ist,
dann nimmst du halt Gnome 3.
Das gibt's.
Aber Debian kassiert ja auch sehr viel
Lob
für ihre Arbeit.
Debian ist kritische Infrastruktur.
Du hast ja
vor ein paar Wochen auf der Fostim
den Greg Crow Hartman
getroffen.
Oder kurz
war. Ich habe mit dem 10 Minuten geredet.
Letzte Woche war CoreOS
Fest in Berlin und
deswegen habe ich auf deren Webseite mal geschaut. Da war
natürlich noch nichts drin. Allerdings
waren die Talks vom letzten Jahr drin und da
hat dieser Herr Hartmann auch ein bisschen gesprochen
über Linux-Körner-Maintaining
und welche Versionen denn long-term
supportet sind.
neben
dem
Debian-Team hat er nochmal
irgendwie Red Hat hervorgehoben, die wohl noch
einen 2.6er-Körner-Maintain und die Debian-Leute
maintain wohl noch einen uralten
3er-Körner.
Das war schon sehr beeindruckend, wie er das
dargestellt hat. Den kann man
sich ja mal anschauen, wenn man so ein bisschen gucken will,
was im Linux-Körner so läuft.
Ich habe
den hauptsächlich erkannt, weil ich Talks von
irgendwelchen Gesprächsrunden, es gibt auch so
regelmäßige Runden, wo
der mit drin sitzt und dann über den State of
Linux redet. Ja, ist auch ein klasse
Redner, muss ich sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der mich verarschert,
aber der hat gemeint, dass ich ihm mal den
Drip-System mit Share in Dresden angeboten haben.
Witzig. Und er konnte halt
nicht viel damit anfangen, weil die hier in Dresden
halt Micro-Core-Nur-Zeugs machen und wir
haben ja eh mittlerweile überall Linux laufen.
Aber vielleicht hätten wir dann hier
in Dresden nur noch über Linux geredet.
Das wäre ja sehr witzig.
Ja.
So viel zum Thema April-Scherze. Das haben wir uns ja alle
durch, den wir uns hier aufgeschrieben haben. Ich sehe noch
einen Tweet von den Matrix-Leuten dazwischen.
Stimmt. Die hatten irgendwie geschrieben,
also Matrix ist ja dieser
Meta-Messenger.
Da habe ich übrigens
Greg Corhartman getroffen.
Ich saß in dem Talk über Matrix drin.
Und Matrix ist ja quasi eigentlich
nur ein Dienst der deiner
Meta-Messenger.
Das ist kein Protokoll.
Also Messaging ist auch...
Das ist quasi, was die machen,
zwischen unterschiedlichen Instanzen von was auch immer.
Die haben ja Schnittstellen zu Jabber,
zu anderen Sachen, zu IAC.
Synchronisieren dir quasi
einfach bloß den Chatverlauf.
Und dadurch hast du halt überall die gleiche
Experience, ob du nur über das oder das oder das
drin bist. Das ist Matrix ein Service.
Matrix ist...
Das kannst du auch selber hosten, aber du kannst auch...
Ich dachte, das ist ein Protokoll, was XMPB ablösen möchte.
Nee.
Okay, dann bin ich völlig informiert.
Dann müssen wir nochmal gemeinsam den Fostentor gucken,
weil ich krieg's auch nicht mehr ganz zusammen.
Ich hab übrigens Matrix-Aufkleber mitgenommen.
Möchte ich jemanden machen?
Schönen Safkleber.
Und ja, die haben
geschrieben, dass sie
ihr Backend, was auf
HTTP und REST basiert, jetzt,
weil es doch schöner ist, mal mit
XMPP bauen wollen.
Und deswegen
haben sie, genau, das haben sie
auch einen Tag später wieder aufgelöst. Wir machen kein
XMPP, wir machen das schön weiter über HTTP.
Ist ja auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Aber, ich meine, so
Messenger ablösen ist schon irgendwie sinnvoll.
Es gibt irgendwie so eine Schwemme in letzter Zeit, das ist ein bisschen
hart.
Wir haben ja hier Sendungsplanungen gemacht.
Am Anfang, bevor wir die ersten
bevor wir die ersten Folgen aufgenommen haben,
da haben wir abwechselnd mal über das FSR-Slack geschrieben.
Über iMessage.
IMessage, seitdem du dann darüber erreichbar warst, ja.
Aber ich bin darüber nur auf Arbeit erreichbar,
weil ich nur auf Arbeit an meinem Mac sitze.
Das ist für dich nur Desktop-Client, ausschließlich.
Ausschließlich, ich habe ja kein iPhone.
Wenn ich mobil unterwegs bin,
dann nehmen wir Signal.
Dann haben wir zum Spaß auch schon mal
über diesen Keybase-IO-Chef-Client-Service gesprochen.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache,
wenn du einmal bei Keybase bist
bei Keybase tragen ja Leute
alle möglichen Social Media Accounts ein.
Also Twitter und GitHub.
Gibt es noch was Wichtiges?
Nein, das war es.
Und dann musst du halt nur
den GitHub Account von jemandem wissen
und kannst mit dem über Keybase chatten.
Der muss natürlich bei Keybase sein.
Ja, und er braucht diesen ekelhaften
Desktop-Client, Elektron-Desktop-Client von denen.
Aber ich finde es eigentlich ganz cool, dass die versuchen
auch GPG...
Deren Absichten sind nobel. Das auf jeden Fall.
von Keybase.
Aber die haben noch ein ganzes Stück Weg
vor sich. Aber die mobilen Apps
wollten die beiden rausbringen.
In dem Announcement von Keybase
Fire System haben die ja schon davon gesprochen,
von Keybase Chat, haben die im Blogpost schon einen Screenshot
von der iOS App gehabt.
Und die gibt es leider noch nicht.
Ich verstehe nicht ganz, wie das funktioniert.
Ich habe auf meinem einen Laptop
in Keybase meinen GPG-Key hinzugefügt,
weil Keybase ja mittlerweile
in PGP
Key-Verwaltungstour ist.
und dann habe ich über deren Mechanismus einen anderen Computer hinzugefügt
und plötzlich konnte ich auf dem Dateien signieren.
Mit deinem alten Key?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen weird.
Dann muss ja der private Key irgendwo langgewandert sein.
Aber egal, wir wollten über Messenger reden.
Was ist denn dein Lieblings-Messenger?
Ich bin ja ganz happy mit Signal.
Ich mache jetzt Videotelefonie mit meinen Eltern über Signal.
Das läuft ziemlich gut.
Was ich an Signal nicht mag, ist zum einen,
dass die beiden
Flagship-Apps von denen, die iOS-App und die Android-Apps,
so featuremäßig weit auseinanderhängen.
Achso.
Die iOS-App hängt immer hinterher,
habe ich das Gefühl. Ich meine, das kann man schlecht Leuten vorwerfen.
Das ist ein Open-Source-Projekt
und es kostet die etwas?
Nee, kostet sie nicht, oder?
Die ist Freeware. Open-Source heißt jetzt nicht in dem Kontext,
aber die ist Freeware. Es ist ein Community-Driven-Projekt,
das Ganze.
Und da passiert halt...
Community-Driven,
Und da ist schon ein festes Team dahinter.
Ja, auch.
Aber wenn ich in das Repo auf GitHub
für die iOS-App mal reinschaue,
dann sind da Leute unzählige von PRs
und da wird einfach wochenlang nicht responded.
Und wenn dann hier, mach mal da was,
okay, ja, super, mach ich mal so und so.
Und dann wird wieder wochenlang nicht responded.
Das schleift ein bisschen. Das finde ich sehr schade manchmal.
Ich finde es schade, dass man
zwar Keys verifizieren kann
gegenseitig, indem man diese QR-Codes scannt,
aber dass man keinen Indikator kriegt,
ob der Key noch derselbe ist.
Du kriegst ja diese Notification.
Ich sage Notification.
Du kannst ja per default nicht mehr mit einer Person schreiben,
sobald sich deren Key ändert.
Das ist ja diese eine Unterscheidung zwischen WhatsApp und Signal,
die so interessant war.
Genau.
Das wäre jetzt eigentlich die perfekte Überleitung zu WhatsApp,
aber ich wollte noch kurz hinzufügen,
dass mich bei Signal nervt.
Das ist der Chrome-App.
Die ist ja gerade der andere Aspekt,
der das Bullshit ist.
Ja, ich finde es erstmal sehr gut,
dass man auf dem Rechner damit schreiben kann,
dass man überhaupt erreichbar ist.
Im Gegensatz, nee, WhatsApp gibt es auch
mittlerweile eine App, aber das war immer so ein Problem.
Das Problem ist, es läuft als
Chrome bei mir.
Das heißt, wenn ich bei mir die Anwendungen
wechsle auf meinem Rechner,
habe ich im Prinzip ein Chrome-Logo und wenn
das dumm läuft, kriege ich immer den Signal-Messenger,
weil der bei mir in dem eigenen Fenster läuft.
Das Problem ist halt auch, es muss Chrome im Hintergrund laufen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du default Chrome-User bist oder nicht,
dann merkst du es wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal so sehr.
Wenn du halt, wie ich Safari nutzt,
und du startest dieses Signal-Tool, dann öffnet sich halt Chrome.
Das Geile ist natürlich auch, wenn man Signal beenden möchte
und ein Q drückt, dann ist Chrome.
Das ist eine Chrome-Package.
Ich benutze Chrome auch nicht, aber wenn ich Signal starte,
dann startet auch Hangouts mit, weil ich das auch
als Chrome-Map bestätigt habe. Aber eigentlich müsste es
doch relativ einfach sein, eine Transition zu machen.
Ich habe das jetzt als Chrome-Map implementiert, das heißt,
das wird wahrscheinlich größtenteils aus JavaScript bestehen.
Und vielleicht ein bisschen natives
Tracks, dann kannst du auch eine elektron-basierte App machen.
Das hat Postman zum Beispiel gemacht.
Das Witzige ist Postman,
dieser REST-Client.
Es gibt diese drei REST-Client.
für macOS, Postman für alle
und Insomnia für alle.
Insomnia ist auch eine Elektron-App, glaube ich.
Ja, und Postman hat eben beides, aber die
bezeichnen ihre Elektron-App als native.
Ja, wie so viele.
Ja, weil sie auch voll native ist.
Das ist aber schon mal dahingestellt. Aber ja,
theoretisch, dass sie eine Elektron-App machen, das würde
bestimmt tausendmal besser laufen,
weil die Chrome-Package-Apps halt schon immer scheiße sind.
Google Sunset hat das ganze Prinzip von Chrome-Package-Apps.
Die sind tot, die gibt es nicht mehr.
Chrome-Package-Apps sind weg.
Google hat das Feature wieder gestrichen und die sind
immer noch eine.
Okay.
Aber...
Es kann noch schlimmer sein.
Du kannst sowas haben wie WhatsApp.
Die haben ja eine Elektron-App.
Und die funktioniert sogar relativ gut.
Echt?
Ja.
Dann dachte die haben bloß diese Web-App.
Das ist die Elektron-App dann.
Achso.
Die kannst du halt auch...
Ganz ehrlich,
wenn du solche Apps rausbringst,
die quasi deine Webseite
in einem Elektron sind,
das gab es schon vor...
Das konntest du schon vor 15 Jahren
mit Firefox machen.
Du kannst einfach sagen,
du rufst Firefox auf
mit Dash Dash, no Chrome.
Also, ja.
Weil Chrome ja die...
No Festa, no UI.
No UI.
Und dann kannst du eine HTTP-Adresse angeben
und dann kriegst du quasi eine neue Firefox-Instanz
ohne Profil und ohne UI,
wo nur diese Webseite dargestellt wird.
In der LAP-Signal läuft das ja prinzipiell alles lokal.
Du hast ja die ganze HTML, CSS, Server Script,
komplett lokal.
Also so, als ob du die Webseite runtergeladen hättest.
Und der Client, der ja dann einfach nur gepackt
dieser Webview ist,
der spricht ja über klassische Technologien,
über JSON, keine Ahnung, wie auch immer.
mit deiner API direkt und mach das darüber.
Also es läuft schon ein bisschen performanter,
als wenn du die Website direkt ansprichst,
aber es ist halt trotzdem ein fucking Chromium, was läuft
und den ganzen Scheiß halt lokal rendert.
Es ist halt auch ein Riesending,
du hast ein Riesen-Framework, was da mitläuft.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sich unterschiedlich...
Mittlerweile hast du wahrscheinlich fünf Elektron-Apps installiert,
wenn du Slack installiert hast.
Hast du mehrere Teams in Slack drin?
Ja.
Jedes Team ist eine eigene Chromium-Instanz.
Die haben es noch nicht hingekriegt, das zusammenzuschieben.
Wir arbeiten dran, aber ich habe es doch nicht hingekriegt.
Aber ich kann auch in einer App zwischen den einzelnen
Ja, und jedes Team ist eine eigene Komis.
Das ist wie ein Fenster, der verschiedene
Browser-Tabs offen hat.
Und jedes Tab ist aber eine komplett laufende
Chromium-Instanz. Jedes Tab dieses Browsers.
Ja, geil, ne? Ja, es ist total geil.
Eigentlich wäre es mittlerweile fast sinnvoll, wenn du diese
Chrome-Runtime als Library installieren könntest,
sodass du die wenigstens die Kaut-Tab teilen kannst.
Du bist so fast ins System-Invekriert.
Ja, und dann bist du an der Stelle, wurde auch vor 15, 20 Jahren
bei Microsoft warst, dass du einfach
den IE nicht deinstallieren kannst.
die eh nicht deinstallieren kannst, weil er in ein System eingebaut ist,
weil er quasi essentielle
Runtime-Umgebung von irgendwelchen anderen
Anwendungen ist.
Die Lawsuit damals habe ich echt bis heute noch nicht
ganz verstanden, warum das denn böse von Microsoft
war. Ich meine, andere App-Dirn machen es ja genauso.
An jeder Ecke hat da immer Software-Fonds installiert.
Aber egal, darum geht es jetzt nicht.
Das kann mir bestimmt niemand erklären.
Was ist denn ein besserer Messenger?
Es gibt keine guten. Das ist das Problem.
Was ist denn zum Beispiel das Problem mit
Freema?
Das ist nur die eine Closed-Source
mobile Variante gibt.
Threema habe ich auch schon seit Ewigkeit nicht mehr benutzt.
Was ich an Threema schön finde,
ist, dass die mit als Einzige
nicht deinen Account
mit deiner Telefonnummer verbinden,
sondern du kriegst eine komische ID.
Aber du brauchst das bestimmt mit dem Telefonnummer anlegen, oder?
Irgendwie ja.
Und dann habe ich aber auch mal das Telefon gewechselt
und ich habe aber keine andere Art und Weise,
diese ID wieder herzustellen.
Du kannst Backups in der App anlegen und die Backup wiederherstellen.
Das habe ich auch schon gemacht.
Das ist noch so ein Ding. Wie mache ich Backups von meinen Accounts?
Bei WhatsApp muss ich das auch wie bei Google hochladen,
damit ich meine Chat-History speichern kann.
Das ist auch ziemlich hässlich.
Unter iOS kann man die, glaube ich, archivieren und rausspeichern
und später wieder einkriegen.
Und WhatsApp schiebt das zurück auch ins iCloud-Backup.
Ja, ins iCloud-Backup auf jeden Fall, aber nur wenn du es aktivierst, glaube ich.
Nur wenn du es aktivierst.
Und das Schöne ist, WhatsApp hat ja sogar mittlerweile
von den Whisper-Systems-Leuten, die die Signal bauen,
ja dieselbe Verschlüsselung bekommen.
So kann man ja zumindest halbwegs...
Ja genau, da gab es neulich diese Meldung,
dass die ein kritisches Sicherheitsproblem
haben und das Sicherheitsproblem ist quasi
der Unterschied lässt sich runterkochen
auf, wenn sich der Key
von jemand anders ändert,
kriegst du bei Signal eine Notification
und kriegst gesagt, der Key
hat sich geändert, möchtest du den wieder bestätigen
und dann musst du es erst manuell bestätigen,
um weiterzuchatten und
WhatsApp hat als Default, dass es einfach
trotzdem weiter mit dir chatten.
Da kriegst du keinen Hinweis, deswegen alle schaut mal
in eure WhatsApp-Einstellung und ändert mal
den Haken auf, bitte
notifiziere mich, wenn sich bei jemand anders der Key ändert.
Das steht dann in der Chat-Fastory drin, das ist tatsächlich
sehr angenehm und man kriegt in der Wand, also so mit,
wenn ihr eure Freunde
ihre Geräte neu aufsetzen,
ist jetzt nicht wichtig, man kriegt auch keine Push-Notes
dafür, aber du kriegst es zumindest mit, wenn du das nächste Mal mit dieser Person
schreibst. Das ist sinnvoll.
Also ich glaube, wenn du redest, brauchen
die Leute, die den Podcast nicht auf doppelte Geschwindigkeit haben.
Sorry. Das habe ich mir aber auch gerade gedacht.
Du hast dich doch noch nicht
beschwert, dass ich meine Signal-Keys ständig
geändert habe. Ja, aber die kriegt man ja Push-Notes,
Bei Signal kriegt man ja Push-Notifications dafür.
Und wenn du dein Gerät fünfmal
in einem Stück neu aufsetzt, dann kriegt
jeder deiner Kontakte fünf Push-Notifications.
Ich habe umgefragt. Ich habe das nicht gemacht.
Wahrscheinlich wurden wir gemanagd mit.
Aber du hast noch die Notifications von Hendrik
genauso bekommen. Ich habe mega viele Notifications
bekommen. Echt? Ja.
Die anderen Leute, die ich gefragt habe, die gesagt haben,
nee, das ist nicht passiert.
Vielleicht ist das wieder so eine kleine Frage bei Signal.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Sie machen aber ständig UI kaputt ins Signal. Das nervt mich.
Das ist nicht schön.
Das ist so ein klassischer in der iOS-Welt,
du willst von der linken Kante in den Bildschirm reinzweiten können,
um zurückzugehen. Das haben sie jetzt explizit überschrieben.
Einer hat den PS wieder ganz gemacht,
das hat Wochen gedauert und jetzt ist es endlich wieder drin.
Das geht mir bei vielen Webseiten auf den Kicks
oder bei vielen Anwendungen auf den Kicks.
Du hast dir mittlerweile eintrainiert, dass wenn oben links
dieses Hamburger-Menü ist, dass du dann von links reinzweiten kannst
und das Menü aufzuziehen.
Bei Android.
Bei manchen Apps geht es halt nicht.
Bei Signal ist es so, dass wenn du von links nach rechts ziehst,
dass du deinen ganzen Thread löscht.
Autsch!
Wo ist das denn sinnvoll?
Dann muss ich immer super schnell auf
andupen.
Das ist ein bisschen schlimm. Aber benutzt
irgendjemand Telegram? Ja, Telegram ist
tatsächlich aktuell, muss ich fast sagen, mein Lieblingsmessenger.
Usability-mäßig, ne?
Von der Usability zum einen.
Es klappt halt einfach wunderbar
schnell und sauber. Es ist auf jeder meiner Plattform
vorhanden. Ich habe viele Kontakte
dort, was natürlich auch immer ein wichtiges Argument ist.
Und sie
Das Riesenproblem daran ist halt, die haben halt keine
Verschlüsselung.
Das Riesenproblem ist,
ich finde, ich habe kein Telegram,
weil ich finde Telegram unwahrscheinlich fishy.
Die haben am Anfang, als sie
die App gestartet haben, haben sie die übelsten
Blockbots gestartet mit, guck mal hier, unsere Krypto ist
viel besser als alle anderen und wir machen das so und so,
was keiner sonst macht. Die ist halt selbstimplementiert,
die Krypto vor allem. Die haben halt ein eigenes
Kryptoprotokoll.
M-Proto heißt das.
Dann liest du aber Nachrichten
auf Heiße, dass du quasi,
dass die ganzen Nachrichten unverschlüsselt auf deren
Server gespeichert werden. Das Problem vor allem
ist ja, dass eine Telegram-Konversation nicht
verschlüsselt ist. Die hat ja nur Transport Security,
nichts anderes. Du bist nur verschlüsselt,
wenn du explizit so einen Secret Chat
startest und dann bist du plötzlich auch an die Plattform
gebunden, von der du diesen Chat initialisiert hast.
Wenn ich dir von meinem iPhone aus, dein Telegram-Konto,
was du jetzt rein hypothetisch mal haben müsstest,
eine verschlüsselte Nachricht schicke, dann sehe
ich die über dem Telegram-Desktop-Klein nicht mehr.
Die ist dann weg.
Die ist dann definitiv end-to-end verschlüsselt.
Wir haben damit das end-to-end
Du kannst es auch end-to-end verschlüsseln
und Keys austauschen und dann trotzdem...
iMessage zum Beispiel hat ja auch end-to-end verschlüsseln
und trotzdem plattformübergreifend und Apple hatte wahrscheinlich
den Master Key. Also irgendwie
machen sie das seltsam. Und was für mich
irgendwie dazukommt, ist, dass das Telegram
geohnt ist von
diesem komischen V-Kontakte.
Ja, das ist ein russischer Konzern.
Und das ist dieses, man sagt immer, das russische
Facebook und die Kombination, die
zwei Begriffe, russisches
Facebook. Das ist aber immer gemein,
weil man hat direkt so ein Bias drin,
wegen russischer Software. Ich weiß auch nicht, wieso.
Es sind nicht so Nachrichten wie die Pegida-Leute
oder die ganzen
Nazis in Sachsen, die schreiben sich nicht mehr auf Facebook,
weil sie wissen, dass sie da zensiert werden. Die gehen ja zu
V-Kontakte und machen dort ihre Kommen.
Ja, toll. Vielleicht schon auch Beinu
oder wie das chinesische Wort heißt.
Also da kannst du sicher sein, dass du zensiert wirst.
Oder dass du mir das mitgelesen wirst.
Halt die Frage, wenn du auf Deutsch schreibst,
musst du es einfach mal besetzen.
Oder du stellst
eine MTU einfach höllisch niedrig ein.
MTU?
Maximum Transfer Unit.
Also das war damals der gängige
Weg, die Great Firewall
in China zu umgehen, dass man einfach gesagt hat,
bitte, liebes Betriebssystem, zerstücke
meine Daten so klein,
dass da quasi kein sinnvolles Wort mehr drin
existiert, sondern nur noch
selben sozusagen. Ein Byte pro Nachricht.
Ein Byte pro Nachricht, ich sag mal im schlimmsten Fall.
Und dann konnte die Great Firewall auf China
die Nachrichten nicht zensieren, weil
nichts zensierenswürdig drin ist.
Was soll an einem A oder an einer Null
zensierenswürdig sein?
Ich habe neulich mal in einem Gespräch jemandem versucht
zu erklären, warum Bitcoin
nicht anonym ist.
Bitcoin ist ja das Gegenteil von anonym.
Bitcoin ist das Gegenteil von anonym, wenn dir einer
nachgewiesen hat, dass du irgendwann ein Key hattest,
dann kannst du auch
den gesamten Geldfluss von diesem
Key nachvollziehen. Wäre es eigentlich praktikabel,
wenn man beim Bitcoin
für jedes, also wenn du
nur noch mit
diskreten Werten arbeiten würdest,
du zerstückelst alles in die
kleinsten mögliche Einheit, was ist das?
Satoshi.
Du machst ein neues
Wallet pro Satoshi.
Damit ich dir
5 Euro überweisen kann,
machst du irgendwie
5000 Überweisungen von 5000 einzelnen
Satoshis oder so.
Ich wette, es gibt einen kleinen, der macht das.
Allein durch die zeitliche Korrelation.
Und dann musst du das natürlich noch
zeitlich ausspalten. Das heißt, ich löse
diese Transaktion auf meinem Client jetzt auf
und der macht das im Laufe einer Stunde
irgendwie in zufälligen. Was die meisten Clients
und was zum Beispiel den ich nutze,
auch tut, ist eine Adresse
pro Transaktion.
Und das hilft schon arg, das auseinanderzuziehen.
Da kriegst du aber dann trotzdem
ja,
aber es reicht nicht ganz.
Das ist halt die Frage, das andere reicht halt
genauso nicht ganz.
Das stimmt.
Das andere ist, kann ich denn so einen Betrag
von einem Konto auf ein anderes Konto
einfach so und das ist mitgeschnitten
nur zu transferieren?
Nein, das muss ja
Aber es geht nur darum, dass du jetzt nicht
sagen kannst, Person A
hat 5 Euro an Person B
überwiesen, sondern
Person A ist 5000
Satoshi-Personen und Person B
ist 5000 andere Satoshi-Personen
und es haben halt 5000 Leute
einen Satoshi an 5000
andere Leute überwiesen jeweils.
Könnte es sein, dass an der Stelle einfach das Volume
auch viel zu fucking hoch wird für die Transaktion?
Ja, natürlich, das würde überhaupt nicht mehr skalieren.
Aber das wäre, glaube ich, die...
Schreibt uns mal Hinweise, ob das
gerade eine Möglichkeit wäre,
Bitcoin zu annehmen. Ich habe
damals gelesen gehabt, als ich noch viel mehr
mit Bitcoin gemacht habe als heute,
dass es, wenn du
jede Transaktion
auf einzelne Wallets aufsplittest,
dass du da schon echt Probleme hast,
Dinge rauszuholen. Natürlich kannst du, wenn du
von jemandem Geld geschickt bekommst, dann weißt du
hundertprozentig, dass dieser Adresse ihm gehörte.
Na genau.
Oder ihr, aber du kannst halt,
wenn die Person es halt auch mit jedem ihrer Transaktionspartner so macht,
dann fällt es dir echt schwer,
Rückschlüsse zu warten. Bestimmte Informationen kannst du immer
aus der Blockchain rausziehen. Sowieso.
Du hast zum Beispiel Probleme,
wenn ich jetzt eine Wallet habe und ich habe da schon 5 Euro
drauf und ich lasse mir
jetzt von jemandem, dem ich Geld gebe, Bargeld gebe,
nochmal 5 Euro überweisen.
Dann lass doch nicht an selbe Konto.
Auf ein anderes Konto.
Dann möchte ich aber was bezahlen, was mehr als 5 Euro kostet.
Dann gibt es
so einen Dienstleister, der macht ein
Wallet auf, auf das ich bezahlen muss
und dann muss ich halt von beiden Konten, damit ich
auf diesen Betrag komme, von beiden Konten auf dieses
eine bezahlt und so sind die beiden jetzt plötzlich
Meter über dieses Ziel-Wallet
noch verlinkt.
Also machst du halt noch in viel Größerem, wenn du
ein einzelner Satoshi-Wallet hast.
Ja, aber dann,
mein Gegenüber darf auch nicht
nur ein Wallet haben.
Du musst quasi für jedes Satoshi ein eigenes Wallet haben.
Du gibst ihm fast die Rechte an den einzelnen Wallets.
Oh,
das wäre fast noch sinnvoller.
Nein, gar nicht.
Weil dann musst du wieder bei dem einen Aspekt, den Bitcoin eben richtig machen.
Es gibt keinen Bitcoin.
Ein Bitcoin ist nichts. Es gibt nicht diese Einheit.
Es gibt nur eine Summe
von Inputs und Outputs.
Deswegen kannst du auch keine Bitcoin fälschen, weil sie einfach
nicht existieren.
Es gibt bloß eine lange, lange, immer wieder
nachvollziehbare Liste von wer hat wem mal Geld
gegeben. Genau, und du musst dir halt komplett
nachvollziehen die Liste, um auch zu finden, wer heute
wie viel Geld hat. Was aber ein lösbares Problem
ist. Ja eben, es bleibt lösbar.
Naja.
Bleibt noch Messenger übrig? Gab es nicht mal einen Bitcoin-basierten
Messenger? Hatten wir über das Thema nicht im letzten
Wir hatten über BitMessage schon gesprochen.
Wir müssen aufpassen, dass unsere Themen in den Podcasts nicht wieder...
Ich hatte noch HipChat aufgenommen, aber ich glaube,
das zählt ja auch nicht so wirklich.
Das kannst du ja irgendwie Slack mit reinschmeißen.
Das ist ja teambasiert und...
Genau, ich habe Slack gelesen und dachte mir,
okay, da fehlt wahrscheinlich noch HipChat. Oh, HipChat fehlt tatsächlich noch.
Ja, aber das ist halt so Business-Fu.
Ja, dann kannst du auch GoToBeating mit auflisten.
Du brauchst halt ein Team dafür erstmal.
Also ich nutze Slack sehr häufig,
aber du brauchst halt, wie gesagt, Teams.
Und du kannst halt nur innerhalb dieser Teams mit diesen Personen schreiben.
Das ist ja bei Slack auch so.
Ja, eben.
Das ist natürlich
ein Anwendungsfall, auf jeden Fall.
Und Slack ist auch gar nicht...
Oder HipChat habe ich jetzt weniger genutzt, aber Slack und HipChat
sind sicherlich gleich mal scheiße. Slack macht das, was sie
machen, sehr gut. Ich würde tatsächlich
hier mal andere Dinge wie RocketChat
oder, wie heißt das,
Mattermost mal ausprobieren.
Oh fuck, das wollte ich eigentlich diese Woche nicht mehr machen.
Voll vergessen.
Zack ist das Wochenende schon wieder vorbei.
Stimmt, ein neues Gip-Lab ist rausgekommen.
Cool.
Stimmt, habe ich sogar gesehen.
Sehr viel schneller geworden.
Oh, das freut mich. Und das MetaMouse,
ist das eigentlich immer mit dabei oder
ist das zum Bezahlen? Ist das ein Premium
Feature? Das ist weder noch,
das ist weder dabei, noch ist es
Premium. Ja, das
MetaMouse ist mir eigentlich nur aufgefallen, was
in diesem Mega-Docker-Image mit drin
auftaucht, neben diesem
GitLab. Dieser Slack-Klon, also die Klonen
explizit und bewusst Slack-Features und
werben die auch immer so an, so hier in einem Change-Log,
das hat Slack jetzt, das haben wir jetzt auch und das
ist auch ein Slack-Feature, das wir jetzt haben und das ist ein Slack-Feature, das wir jetzt haben,
Bin ich mega geil.
Ich habe immer so ein bisschen Angst davor,
aber die sind da völlig unverfroren.
Habt ihr mal nachgeguckt, wo GitLab sitzt?
Vielleicht in irgendeinem Land, wo das nicht passiert.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, aber mir ist es da nur aufgefallen,
dass es halt in diesem Docker-Ding mit drin ist.
Da dachte ich mir, vielleicht ist es auch
in der Hauptanwendung irgendwie mit eingebaut.
So weit, ich weiß nicht.
Die bauen ja viele Dinge ein, aber das ist gut eingebaut.
Aber MetaMose an sich ist ja wirklich genauso
wie Slack und HipChat da in selbe Kategorie von Messaging Client.
Gibt es da auch eine Elektronanwendung
als Native? Ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher, aber ich
weiß es nicht hundertprozentig. Ich würde zu 80%
ja sagen, aber ich habe sie noch nicht probiert.
Was ist, wo wir noch
nicht drüber gesprochen hatten beim
Messaging, ist natürlich das, was
viele unserer Hörer für haten,
Jabber und XMPP Clients.
Ja, es gibt immer mal wieder schöne neue,
aber das Problem ist, es gibt kein Incentive dafür,
selber einen Server zu besitzen.
Es gibt ja genug Server.
Da gab es diese wunderschöne Übersicht von diesem
Gulch. Hast du, wenn du
noch einen Link irgendwo findest, ich hab den nochmal gesucht,
hab den nicht mehr gefunden, von Jabba-Servern, welche
XAPs die implementieren?
Ja, da gab's eine Tabelle und der, bei dem
ich meinen Jabba mittlerweile habe,
hatte da noch so ein paar
rote Felder und ich hab die angeschrieben und
eine Woche später waren es grüne Felder, das fand ich sehr gut.
Das war sehr toll. Das war wunderschön.
Ich bin aktuell bei Jabba.cat, also
.katalonien, und bin
sehr glücklich bei dem, weil die haben auch tatsächlich
Support-Shirts für die XAPs.
Wenn du eine.cat-Domain hast, dann musst du doch auch katalonischen
deren Stabseite ist auch auf Katalonisch.
Unterwendig.
Musst du jetzt selber
auf Katalonisch schreiben?
Nö, nö. Ich versuch's, aber
ich hab halt keine Ahnung. Ich hab letztens
im C3D2
Headquarter, war ich mal.
Und da sind ja auch sehr viele
XMPP-Nerds anzutreffen.
Darf ich mich mal kurz? Viele Grüsse.
Ja, garantiert. Oder komm mal mit
vorbei. Hab ich nochmal
nachgefragt, weil ja
E-Jabber-D so ein bisschen in die
Werkecke abdriftet im Moment
mit ihren Release-Nummern und dem gesamten Setup.
Da hat so ein erleichterter
im C3D2 gemeint, naja,
es gab wohl mal Bestrebungen,
E-Jobody 3 rauszubringen,
bei dem der Fokus
darauf lag, statt Strings,
was in Erlangen wohl verkettete
Listen von Bytes... Erlangen kann keine Strings.
...richtig auf Binary umzuschwenken.
Das haben die aber dann abgebrochen
und haben das so gelassen, wie es ist.
Das war kein Affe-Scherz, oder?
Nope. Nope.
Und Mongoose
hat das wohl durchgezogen.
Wir haben E-Jabody geforked und haben
das Binary-Zeug durchgezogen.
Ich habe es bisher noch nicht
zu laufen. Was ist Mongoose? Das ist ein Fork
von E-Jabody, oder? Richtig, richtig.
Ich habe es bisher noch richtig aufgesetzt,
habe mir das Docker-Image mal angeschaut und da war halt
irgendwie so ein, die haben dann so Magic gemacht,
wenn der Hostname eine Eins
am Ende hat, dann ist es automatisch der Cluster-Master
und die haben das halt mega
auf, wir betreiben hier 20.000
Server dafür ausgelegt.
Und dann habe ich einfach mal noch einen Pull-Request gestellt und gesagt,
können wir da mal eine Umgebungsvariable einbauen,
damit ich das Ding auch alleine betreiben kann.
Und er meinte, da kann ich das auch nochmal verifizieren für Slaves,
also für den Rest.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, so mache ich mal,
aber bisher bin ich leider noch nicht dazu gekommen.
Wo du gerade von Umgebungsvariablen redest,
kannst du mir erklären, was eine 12-Faktor-App ist?
Ja.
Da gibt es einen Link zu.
Das ist ein Pattern.
Und da geht es darum,
Eine Anwendung, es geht darum, der Anwendung Umgebungsvariablen mitzugeben
und damit das generelle Verhalten zu steuern.
Das heißt, ich gebe zum Beispiel die Datenbankverbindung für diese App an.
Oder, was natürlich noch mega deutlich besser ist,
ich gebe irgendwie einen Konfiberations-Endpunkt der App,
sodass sie dort ihre detaillierten Einstellungen bekommt.
Und dann soll alles über Standard-In und Standard-Out funktionieren,
damit ich die App möglichst gut als Docker-Service irgendwo laufe?
Nein, ganz im Gegenteil.
Ich habe es aus der Ecke Ruby on Rails mitbekommen.
Und da geht es im Prinzip,
eine Rails-App braucht im Wesentlichen zwei Umgebungsvarianten,
damit sie starten kann.
Und zwar einmal die Database-URL.
Das ist einfach ein String, wo drin steht,
welchen Typ Datenbank mit welchen Benutzernamen
und welchem Passwort und wo läuft das ganze System.
Das muss ich angeben.
Und als nächstes muss ich noch eine Secret Keybase angeben,
mit dem Ruby on Rails die Cookies erzeugt.
signiert. Aber
der Hintergrund dieser ganzen Geschichte ist,
dass diese Anwendung
quasi keine Konfigurationsdateien braucht,
sondern einfach, um die über die Umgebungsvariablen
konfiguriert wird.
Laut 12factor.net, eine Seite, über die ich letztens gestoppt bin,
ist das Faktor 3 der
12 Factors, die alle
so Dinge sind, auf die man achten sollte.
Du hast eine Codebase, die
in Revision Control liegt und du achtest darauf,
Dinge zu stagen und getestet
zu haben und dann auf den Production zu pushen.
Du hast Dependencies, die sauber isoliert sind.
Das heißt, es ist hauptsächlich für Web-Anwendungen.
Die wollen nicht so spezifisch, glaube ich, sein.
Ich habe jetzt eine kleine Anwendung,
die wird von anderen Leuten benutzt,
das ist aber eine Kommandozeilen-Anwendung.
Es ist sinnvoll, die in Richtung
12-Factor-App zu finden.
Viele der Faktoren spielen eine Rolle.
Wir packen die Seite einfach mit in die Show-Noten rein.
Aber ich finde es schön, dass das mal jemand formuliert hat,
weil zu dem Zeitpunkt, als ich das erste Mal
von 12-Factor gehört habe,
gab es sowas noch nicht.
Da hat man halt immer hier und da mal gesucht.
Das ist also eine gefühltige Reihe an Conventions, die sinnvoll sind.
Ja, ja.
Du kannst natürlich auch deine Database-Handle hardcoden, aber das ist halt dumm.
Ja, du kannst es auch nur in ein Config-File reinschreiben,
aber dann musst du jedes Mal dafür sorgen, dass diese Config-File irgendwie existiert.
Ja, und wo liegt das in deinem Git-Repo und dann musst du plötzlich Changes damit reinschreiben?
Ja, hallo, hast du da ein Git-Repo?
Ja, ist halt immer so eine Frage. Es gibt halt Dinge, wo Conventions bekannt sind und darauf zu achten.
Genau, genau.
Wo waren wir kurz davor noch bei Jabber-Clients? Es gibt ja keine guten Jabber-Clients.
Unsere Themen sind Nativensuche quasi.
Natürlich.
Viel Spaß beim Chapter Mark setzen.
Werde ich haben.
Es gibt ja wie gesagt keine guten Jabber Clients.
Diese Diskussion hatte ich tatsächlich das letzte Mal,
vor ein paar Stunden.
Es gibt genau einen guten Jabber Client da draußen.
Einen einzigen, der meiner Meinung nach gut ist.
Und das ist Conversations für Android.
Ja, schönen Gruß an den Autor,
den wir gerade eben eh schon namentlich erwähnt haben.
Daniel Gulsch, genau.
Was ist mit anderen iOS?
Für iOS ist die Lage richtig traurig.
Es gibt ChatSecure,
der ist halbwegs sinnvoll
und kann tatsächlich Chat,
aber wie jede iOS-App
in der Liga stirbt sie halt
zehn Minuten, nachdem du sie letztes Mal offen gehabt hast,
weil sie im Backhand gekillt wird.
Da gibt es eigentlich auch Wege drumherum, meiner Meinung nach.
Ich hatte mal
B-Jive-EM.
Stimmt, die gab es auch mal. Das waren so generell
alles Handle-Leute.
Ja, das war so ein mega großes Teil
so eine App, die alle möglichen Protokolle
sprechen wollte.
Hat die dann einfach auf LibPurple basiert?
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich bin schon relativ groß.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr so hundertprozentig erinnern.
Und ich kann auch nur sagen,
es war so ein bisschen fishy,
weil man hat sich irgendwie bei denen,
also nicht bei denen registriert,
sondern man konnte zu einem beliebigen Java-Server
eine Verbindung aufbauen.
Aber irgendwie wurde das bei denen
auf dem Server die Verbindung aufgebaut.
Und zur eigentlichen App
gab es nur generelle
Kommunikation, aber
irgendwie hat deren Server die Verbindung
offen gehalten, sodass, wenn dir irgendjemand
eine Nachricht geschrieben hat,
die eine Push-Nachricht absetzen konnten,
sodass die App auf deinem iOS-Grad
Das war damals auch die einzige Art und
Weise, wie du sowas machen konntest. Es gab kein
Backgrounding in iOS damals, als BGF groß war.
Das waren so iOS 2, 3
Zeiten vor allem, wo das richtig bekannt war.
Und die App seitdem, glaube ich, ist relativ gestorben.
Vielleicht gar nicht, ob sie überhaupt noch gibt.
Ich bin bei iOS 5 dazugekommen,
zu iPhone und
da gab es die noch.
Und ich glaube, ich habe sie
nicht mehr installiert, aber ich kann ja mal kurz rein.
Aber das war damals die einzige Möglichkeit, sowas zu tun.
Ich meine, heute gibt es XePs, die
ein ähnliches Verhalten basteln, aber dass
dein Java-Server halt die Verbindung mehr oder weniger
offen hält und dir einfach dann eine Notification
schickt und dann kann dein Client halt damit umgehen.
Es gab ja schon
vor Jahren
diese Gateways in Java,
als Leute noch ICQ benutzt haben,
dass du das nicht machen musst.
eine Liste von Fernsehpouts.
Ja, es gab ICQ-Gateways, da hast du quasi
auf deinem Jabber-Server deine ICQ-Nummer
und Passwort eingegeben und dann hat dir das
eine Gateway hinzugefügt und dann hast du deine ganzen ICQ-Accounts
per
ICQ-Nummer.ICQ.
dein Jabber-Server als
Kontext bekommen. Prinzipiell finde ich solche
Gateways immer lustig. Slack hat ja so ein blauer IOC-
und Jabber-Gateways. Du kannst Slack auch über IOC- und Jabber nutzen.
Du musst ja bloß ein gewisses Feature-Set von Slack
dafür wegwerfen. Was ich ziemlich funny fand,
war
der Jabber-to-Tapper. Jabber-to-Jabber
Transport.
So was wollte ich mal bauen. Ja, das gab's
tatsächlich und das Schöne daran
war, man konnte damit zum Beispiel an
seinem normalen Roster, den man in
XMPP hat, Facebook
anbinden. Genau. Man konnte Studi4Z
anbinden. Das waren ja früher alles bei XMPP-Versier.
Das waren ja auch alles XMPP-Zeiten.
Wahrscheinlich immer noch XMPP-Versier. Facebook nicht mehr.
Facebook ist weggegangen, als sie Gruppenchat
eingeführt haben. Okay. Und
das war halt immer recht schön, weil dann hattest du
wirklich einen Jabber-Client auch auf dem Handy,
in dem alle deine Kontakte
drin waren. Und das war nicht
Multiprotokoll, sondern das war ein Backend
XMPP und dann hat ein Server
den Spaß. Vielleicht schafft Matrix
mal das alles zerschlagen,
aber ich rechne auch nicht mehr
damit, dass das so ist.
Ja, sehr schön. Gerade wo wir es genannt
haben mit, es gibt noch einen Messenger, den viele Leute
nutzen, das ist der Facebook Messenger, den haben wir gar nicht angesprochen.
Der hat tatsächlich auch eine schöne User Experience, muss ich sagen.
Ja, aber ich nutze ihn überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe keine Kontakte mehr.
Aber tatsächlich, Facebook, der einzige Existenzgrund
für Facebook mittlerweile, für mich
ist wirklich nur noch
Real-World-Kontakte.
Ich bin da mit Leuten verknüpft,
die ich zur Schule gegangen bin,
die ich in person
getroffen habe.
Das ist so der Ersatz fürs Telefon.
Das ist so eine Art öffentliches Kontaktbuch.
Das ist eine Art Dressbuch.
Ja genau, Dressbuch meine ich.
Aber
Plattform halt Schrott.
Aber er hat tatsächlich
eine schöne User Experience.
Das stimmt. Der Messenger funktioniert echt ganz gut,
wenn man ihn mal nutzt.
Was ist eigentlich mit Twitter?
Also Twitter ist für mich das bessere Facebook.
Auf Facebook bist du mit den Leuten befreundet,
die du persönlich kennst.
Auf Twitter bist du mit den Leuten befreundet,
mit denen du Interessen teilst.
Das ist nur die Trennung.
Twitter kannst du auch Direct Messages schicken.
Das ist auch wieder eine Kleinfrage.
Twitter hat halt dieses witzige Phänomen,
dass viele Leute neuerdings,
sag ich mal,
in der Twitter-Timeline,
also nicht der Timeline-Feature auf Twitter,
sondern seitdem es Twitter gibt,
nutzen die offiziellen Clients erst seit kürzerer Zeit sehr viele Leute.
Früher war jeder auf einem Third-Party-Client.
Ich habe mal einen Third-Party-Client ausprobiert,
weil bei Twitter zwischendurch immer mal ein bisschen Werbung steht.
Aber was hatte ich da? Phoenix oder sowas?
Phoenix hat doch ganz gut sein, dachte ich.
Und das fand ich echt...
Tatsächlich ist der Twitter-Hauptclient...
Ich bin damit ziemlich happy.
Ich nicht. Ich mag Tweetbot.
Ich mag auch Tweetbot.
Es ist nur ein bisschen nervig,
aus meiner RSS-App immer auf Twitter
zu kommen, weil irgendwie auf meinem Handy
der Twitter-Web-Client total tot ist.
Ich kann auf meinem iPhone
keine Twitter-Seite momentan öffnen.
Es stürzt einfach ab. Aber es lädt ewig,
es hängt, keine Ahnung was.
Und ja, es ist halt nervig.
Und über Deep-Linking funktioniert das halt mit
Tweetbot auch nicht. In manchen Apps kannst du halt
einstellen, hey, in welchem Client
wissen du Twitter-URLs?
Da müssen die Entwickler halt wissen,
was sind so typische Twitter-Clients und dann schreib es halt
für die drei populären Reihen, für Twitter, für Tweetbot
Riffic. Und das war es dann.
Nutzen wir Leute überhaupt noch Twitter Riffic?
Das kommt ja bald wieder. Keine Ahnung.
Es kommt wieder. Ich habe davon noch nie gehört.
Twitter Riffic war der erste
Third-Party-Twitter-Klein. Das sind die, die das
Wort Tweet erfunden haben. Das kommt nicht von
Twitter. Und
die haben sich vor kurzem einen Kickstarter
gestartet, wo sie die Desktop-App,
die jetzt so lange keine Absatz mehr bekommen hat,
komplett neu schreiben wollen. Und der Kickstarter
war ein Riesenerfolg. Und die haben
eine riesengroße Fangemeinde und
ich freue mich drauf, dass die auch wieder was Neues basteln.
Das waren richtig tolle Leute.
Die ersten Leute, die den Begriff
To Tweez
geprägt haben. Ich habe vorhin was sehr Schönes geguckt.
Das war schon aus dem Februar, aber ich hoffe,
davon gibt es mehr Folgen. Das muss ich euch mal teilen.
Das ist was für die Show Notes. Es gibt die
Fake News Show.
Das ist so eine Quiz Show. Das ist so ein bisschen
QI-mäßig, so britisch.
Die Sendung, die Folge, die ich vorhin geguckt habe,
ich weiß nicht, ob es mehrere Folgen gibt,
war mit dem einen
Darsteller aus
die IT-Crowd als Gast.
Und da geht es quasi um Fake News und was ist Fake News?
Und man plötzlich gegenseitig fragen und dann zeigen sie so ein Foto von der Inauguration Crowd von Trump.
Und fragen, was ist das nicht?
Und dann sagt einer, das ist nicht meine Geburtstagsfeier.
Und dann zum Schluss kommt, was ist das nicht?
Und dann zeigen sie Sean Spicer, this is the biggest crowd that ever would have this inauguration period.
Also das ist so eine typische britische Panel Show.
Genau, und die hatten irgendwie die Aufgabe bekommen,
vor der Sendung in Vorbereitung
Fake News über Twitter zu verteilen
und haben dann Punkte dafür bekommen, wer die meisten
Likes bekommen hat oder den meisten
den größten Impact hatte.
Und der eine hat irgendwie eine Quizshow mit
Promis gehabt und hat dann irgendwie gepostet, dass er
Kanye West eingeladen hat und
das hat nicht gestimmt und dann haben ihm die Leute von
Kanye West angeschrieben.
Also ich weiß nicht, was hier rausgekommen ist,
aber Kanye West hat eigentlich zu der Zeit keine,
kann leider nicht, aber wir könnten dir
P. Diddy anbieten.
Das ist geil.
Achso, genau.
Da hat eine Typ
in einem Satz wirklich gesagt,
there was the most
so ein Begriff Tweet,
that was the most
most popular thing I ever twat.
Twat.
Tweet, twat, twat. Das ist auch eine Art und Weise,
das zu konjugieren. Ja, das klingt jetzt auch
spontan nicht falsch, aber
halt bescheuert. Das klingt schon sehr falsch.
Twat ist ja eine Beleidigung.
Ja, Twit heißt Fotze.
Okay.
Es klingt
dennoch grammatikalisch
korrekt an der Stelle, muss ich sagen.
Ja, das ist so wie...
Ja, es klingt bekloppt, wie bescheuert.
So wie ich...
Tweeted klingt halt auch...
Das klingt einfach nur, als ob du Grammatik nicht verstanden hast.
Aber es heißt...
Tweeted.
Aber es ist so wie, ich schrob.
Ich schrob.
Ich mag eigentlich solche...
Wortkonjugierte Verben.
Das ist gerade nicht richtig.
Je mehr konjugiert, desto besser ist es.
Im Deutschen ist doch die Grundregel,
eigentlich musst du den Konsonanten das Verb reinbringen,
der am unlogischsten klingt.
Und dann hast du die korrekte Form.
Nee, da gibt es Ablautreihenfolgen.
Aha.
Wie?
Naja.
Warte mal, hast du jetzt Englisch gesagt?
Im Deutschen.
Nee, im Deutschen tatsächlich.
Also seitdem ich...
Das ist doch eine gute Infoquelle.
Seitdem ich mit meiner besseren Hälfte zusammen bin,
die Germanistik studiert.
Die Germanistik studiert, habe ich unglaublich viel
über solche Sachen gelernt und tatsächlich gibt es
da ein Regelwerk dahinter,
welches Wort konjugiert wird.
Aber das würde ja heißen, dass wir
das alle intuitiv tun, oder?
Jein.
So etwas entsteht doch eher automatisch.
Nein, wir können das intuitiv, das geht bei
vielen Wörtern ganz intuitiv,
bei manchen Wörtern ist es schwierig
und in dem Moment konjugiert man meistens schwach.
Dann kommt so etwas wie
habe geschrieben.
Und nicht grob, weil grob halt
echt aufwendig ist und in dem Moment
muss man auch so ein bisschen nachdenken und es ist halt
keine Ahnung wie im Quintenzirkel,
wenn da halt irgendwie
eine enharmonische Verwechslung
vorliegt oder so und man halt umdenken
muss. Und das ist ein gutes Regelwerk, wenn es
halt intuitiv meistens stimmt
und das ist halt sinnvoll von dir. Ja, richtig und das
haut fürs meiste hin und für den normalen
Sprachgebrauch. Aber wenn es halt ein bisschen
seltener wird, dann muss man halt kurz nachdenken,
was es ist. Bisschen bezweckt. Und in dem Moment
konjugiert man es eher
Schwach, weil da gibt es halt ein wesentlich
einfacheres Pattern mit
Rabe geschrieben. Das ist ja beim Konjunktiv
nicht anders, diese Würdeform. Da gibt es ja auch meistens noch
diese andere Form von
ich weiß nicht, wie man die nennt, wo du es halt auch
bescheuert klingst, aber ich finde das
viel interessanter, viel
erhabener. Ja eben,
das macht die Sprache erst richtig schön, wenn man sie
so richtig ausnutzt. Das ist wie
Isn't insofern.
Ja, weil man so richtig die Sprachmittel nutzen kann.
Achso, ganz kurz,
Themenumschwung komplett.
Das heißt übrigens, glaube ich, idiomatisch.
Ah, schön.
Ein April-Scherz, der mir gefehlt hat dieses Jahr,
ist irgendein Blog-Post von den Go-Entwicklern,
das sind Generics.
Ach, echt? Machen sie nicht?
Gab es aber nicht.
Da habe ich zumindest nicht gesehen.
Ist eigentlich Heinrichschen in April geschickt worden?
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin mir immer noch nicht sicher,
ob diese Swift-Umbenennung nun stimmt oder nicht.
Habt ihr irgendwas geglaubt?
Meine Mom hat mich angerufen
und mir gemeint, sie steht von mir vor der Tür.
Ich habe es erst nicht geglaubt, bis sie halt mehrfach gesagt hat,
dass sie bei mir vor der Tür steht.
Und dann habe ich sie geglaubt.
Und dann stand sie bei ihr vor der Tür.
Dann meinte sie, April April.
Meine Mama kommt immer mit diesem bullshitigen,
total unlustigen kleinen April-Schatz,
aber ich falle jedes verschissene Jahr drauf rein.
Ich bin immer unlustig, aber sie sind halt immer so
minimal so, ne, ich liege aber gerade
im Alarm-Alautpark.
Ich bin so ein bisschen in April geschickt worden, und zwar
Deine Mama ist voll lustig.
Soge ich letzte Woche rum?
in eine neue WG.
Und unsere Mitbewohnerin, die wollte uns tatsächlich
glauben machen, dass ihre Oma demnächst mal hier übernachten
muss, weil bei ihrer Family kein Platz
ist zur Zeit, kein Bett frei wäre.
Und genau.
Und ich glaube, in dem Moment, als ich gefragt habe, wie alt ist denn deine Oma
eigentlich, hat
sie dann gesagt, ja, ja, April, April.
Und ihr Freund ging schon mit der Hand am Kopf
zur Tür raus.
Also der war echt gut gemacht.
Hat das Alter der Oma denn für dich einen Unterschied
in der Akzeptanz dieser Aussage gespielt?
Nö, nö, das ist halt nur die Frage, weil wir haben
in der Wohnung...
Das ist eine behinderlichere Gerechte Wohnung
und dann muss man halt so unterlegen, kommt die jetzt vielleicht doch
im Rollstuhl? Es wäre krass, wenn sie das noch so
elaboriert hätte. Ja, sie kommt und sie ist 94
und übrigens
sie sitzt im Rollstuhl und sie hat
einen Katheter und
es wäre ganz cool,
wenn einer von euch sich opfern würde,
weil ich bin nicht so stark, der ihr dann hilft,
aufs Klo zu gehen oder sowas.
Wenn du sowas eiskalt durchziehst,
dann könntest du dir die Lüge ganz schnell reißen.
Manche Leute überlegen sich halt die
Story vor ihnen ein und geben halt richtig Mühe rein.
Ja, eben.
Ich liebe sowas. Ich mach das überhaupt gerne.
Das sind dann halt auch solche Leute,
die sechs Insidiger RFCs schreiben.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Oder halt ein Feature implementieren für eine Sprache.
Fuck, die Aufnahme läuft gar nicht.
Abhol, abhol.
Boah, du Arme!
Ich war kurz geschockt.
Ja, oh Gott.
Sehr geil.
Es ist ja fucking 2. April, Mann.
Wir wollten eine ernste Folge
drehen. Sorry, weint man doch.
Komm, ne, auf, weißt du auch.
Ah, so.
Ja, gut, alle Messengers sind scheiße.
Das Thema sei hiermit beendet. Schreibt uns doch mal,
wenn ihr noch Messenger nutzt, die wir noch nicht angesprochen haben.
Gibt ja viele. Wir haben ja vorhin über
chinesische Seiten gesprochen. Da gibt es ja auch noch WeChat,
was sehr populär ist für Millionen Leute auf der Welt.
QQ. Es gibt Wire, QQ.
Ach, Wire.
Stimmt. Das ist ja kein chinesisches Ding.
Das ist auch aus der Schweiz, glaube ich.
Ja, aber es ist auch scheiße.
Zählt eigentlich SSH und Screen?
Nur wenn du über...
Wie heißt dieses?
Wie heißt das?
Wall oder WeAll?
Achso.
Was?
Ich schäme mich fast dafür.
Wir sprechen die ganze Zeit über Messenger.
Und wir haben einen sehr relevanten XKCD.
Der ist jetzt der vorvorletzte XKCD oder so.
Ich muss kurz die Nummer raussuchen.
Suche.
Ach der mit dem
Wend-Diagramm an Messengern.
Genau, Chat-Systems, XCAD 1810.
Es geht darum, welche
von einer Freundeskreise sind in welchen Messengern
und das ist halt, unten in der Ecke ist einer,
der über VR oder Wall, wie man es ausspricht,
in Klammern Unix erreichbar ist
und daneben einer Wall Bathroom
und dann zwei
The Chat Tab in ein old
Google Doc. Die meisten
damit überschneiden sich irgendwie aus E-Mail, SMS,
iMessage, Slack, IRC,
Instagram DM, Twitter DM,
Telegram, eine in der Ecke, eine ist
Apache Request Log. Kannst du das nochmal in die Show
schreiben? Auf jeden Fall, 1810 ist die
Nummer. Das ist E-Clearance
House of Gable.
Das ist ein wunderschöner X-CD und der Spiegel hat dieses Problem
mit Messengern so gut
wieder, weil du hast immer auf jeder
Plattform einen Subset deiner Kontakte. Es gibt doch
dieses Spiel, dass du von jeder Wikipedia
Seite innerhalb von 6
Klicks zu Hitler kommst.
Ich kenne es mit Philosophie,
aber das wäre ja schon schlimm, weil das wäre
größer und besser, als man alle erreichen
könnte bei einem generischen Thema.
Das heißt, es steht im Prinzip dafür, dass du
innerhalb von sechs Klicks auf jede
Wikipedia-Seite von Wikipedia-Seite
auf jede andere Wikipedia-Seite bekommen kannst.
Aber witzigerweise, was wir herauszufinden,
in deinem Bekanntenkreis, es gibt ja Leute,
die du auf bestimmten Messengern nicht erreichst.
Also mich kriegst du auf Telegram nicht.
Aber wenn jemand, der zum Beispiel kein Signal hat,
mich erreichen will, der was in Telegram hat,
dann könntest du ja sagen, naja,
pass auf, du könntest ja den anschreiben, der hat Signal
und Telegram und dem sag mal, schreib mal bitte
auf Signal weiter.
Ruchenkontakte, oder?
Jetzt musst du dir in deinem Freundeskreis
Leute suchen, die um eine
möglichst lange Kette aufbauen können, dass du
eine Nachricht schickst, die einmal über alle Messenger geht.
Und zwar aus
Necessity, weil die Leute, die da dazwischen
sind, diese Überschneidung nicht haben.
Eigentlich nutzt du ja nur die Fakultätsfunktion.
Das heißt, du müsstest theoretisch
N-1 Leute in deiner
Freundesliste anschreiben. Weil ich dich ja
nicht erreichen kann über Telegram,
müsste ich alle anderen meine Freunde
anschreiben über Whatever.
Außer dich.
Whatever wäre übrigens ein wunderschöner
Meta-Messenger-App-Name.
Das heißt eigentlich WhatsApp, sondern
Whatever.
Set mir ein Whatever.
Just drag me a message on Whatever.
Das ist ja dieses Small World...
Das ist ja das
Small World Syndrome unserer Zeit,
dass wir im Prinzip über sieben Ecken
mit jeder anderen Person...
Jeder chinesische Reisbauer sechs Ecken zu Britney Spears.
mal die Studie dieses
Paper-Retschen?
Ich frage irgendjemanden
anderen.
When are we?
Whatever.
Nee, ist eine schöne Excesi, die muss
auf jeden Fall angesprochen werden, zu diesem
Thematik allgemein.
Gut, ich würde sagen,
wir gehen aber mal ein Thema weiter,
um das mal abzuschließen.
Wir heißen Akronymisierbar, aber wir reden nicht über
Akronyme. Warum sind wir eigentlich auf diesen Namen gekommen?
Wir könnten an dieser Stelle
einen einstündigen Einschnitt machen
und unsere komplette mit aufgenommene
Namensfindung mit einspielen.
Wo wir aber
interessanterweise nicht mehr auf den Namen Akonis überkamen,
sondern den kamen wir erst zwei Tage später.
Da haben wir beschlossen,
uns Naming Things zu nennen, wenn du dich erinnerst.
Oh, das war eine scheiße Idee.
Whatever.
Naming Things ist hart.
Whatever wäre auch ein schöner Podcast.
Ah ja, voll gut.
Because we talk about whatever.
Lenn es nochmal um.
Und dann wäre das Akronym dann
WE.
Wir nennen übrigens diese Folge
Whatever.
Aber was haltet ihr von der Kategorie
Akronym der Woche?
Finde ich sehr spannend.
Hat jemand ein cooles Akronym?
Ja, und zwar hatte ich eigentlich
die Idee beim GitHub Starterwoche
was dazu zu sagen.
Das ist aber ein bisschen länglich.
Deswegen bringe ich jetzt das Akronym der Woche
HAXM. H-A-X-M geschrieben.
Und das steht quasi für
das Pendant für KVM
auf Windows und macOS.
Und ich berühre das heute, weil
Coemu gerade an der Version 2.9
bastelt.
Und die kriegen endlich Huxim-Support. Das heißt,
man kann bald Coemu
auf Windows auf jeden Fall und hoffentlich auch
auf Mac
hart aber schon nicht ausführen. Also quasi mit
Virtualisierungserweiterungen. Und deswegen
kann ich dann mein VMware und mein Virtualbox
und mein Parallels
alles deinstallieren, weil ich es nicht mehr brauche, weil ich
ganz schnell Coemu habe.
Genau wie auf Linux.
Was ist da das Zeitfenster?
Wann rauskommen?
QEMU 2.9 wird bald rauskommen.
Und dann benutzt es auf Linux
immer noch KVM oder auch Huxim?
Nee, auf Linux verwendest du KVM.
Aber das Problem ist, QEMU hatte bisher
nur diese KVM-Schnittstelle
für Linux.
Jetzt musst du aber echt mal erzählen, was diese Akronyme heißen.
KVM heißt
Kernel Virtual Machine.
Genau, und Huxim heißt
Hardware Accelerated Execution Manager.
Cool, ich muss aber auch eine Abkürzung.
Quick Amulator.
Der ist in C geschrieben,
der müsste man mal etwas sicher machen.
Nachdem vor einem Jahr
ungefähr mal ein Kommilitone zu mir kam
und mich gefragt hatte,
Steiger, kennst du denn eigentlich eine Methode,
wie wir auf unserem kleinen Dell-Rechner
mit, ich glaube,
einen Terabyte-RAM irgendwie
zwei VMs mit jeweils 512
Gigabyte RAM betreiben können, weil wir da
Simulationen laufen lassen. Und in Virtualbox
ist das irgendwie langsam. Die Kista hat glaube ich
48 Kammern. Meinte ich doch,
probier doch mal Cuemo dafür.
So, und
Cuemo ist doch ganz schnell, wenn man es mal
vergleicht. Und die kriegen das richtig sauber hin.
Und ich freue mich drauf, wenn es auf dem Mac läuft.
Weil dann kann ich endlich den anderen
Käsehle das komplett weghauen und kann
mich auf meine Shell-Skripte zurückziehen.
Also, Cuemo gab es bislang
immer nur auf Linux? Ne, das läuft
auf jedem Mist, aber der Punkt ist,
schnell läuft es eigentlich nur, wenn du
irgendwie eine Schnittstelle hast, die
unterstützt wird auf der Plattform.
Und in Linux ist es halt KVM,
KVM ist richtig schnell, gibt es aber
halt nur für Linux.
Und dort im Prinzip kriegst du nur die
Hardware durchgereicht, die auch da ist. Das heißt, auf einem
Intel-System kriege ich einen Intel-Prozessor schnell,
auf einem Raspberry Pi,
sage ich jetzt mal, kriege ich einen ARM-Prozessor
recht schnell.
Und unter Windows und unter macOS gibt es
Schnittstelle KVM einfach nicht.
Und dort gibt es Haxen, das kommt aus der
Android-Welt, das kommt von Android Studio
und von dem Simulator.
Und der Android Studio Simulator
basierte irgendwann mal auf
Cuemo und der
wie Peloton auf
GitHub hat dann den Code
rausgezogen aus dem Simulator
und in Cuemo reingepatcht.
Der gute Besitzer wahrscheinlich
keinen Mac, deswegen hat er den Mac-Code erst mal
rausgehauen und nur die Windows-Schnittstelle
gebaut. Aber ich glaube echt, dass da
Leute, die das einfach mal für Mac nachbauen.
Das ist echt stark.
Looking forward to see the comments.
Ich hatte gestern mal wieder
einen Windows-Rechner auf dem Schoß
in meiner Freizeit.
Achso, du warst daheim.
Ich war daheim bei meinen Eltern.
Ich habe erstmal deren Druckerprobleme gelöst.
Großartig.
Und dann habe ich mir tatsächlich
die Rust-Toolchain auf Windows installiert.
Ich habe ja diese kleine Notification-Library
about Rust Notify. Ich schäme mich,
ich höre ihn noch für diesen Namen, der ist tatsächlich nicht gut.
Notify Rust meinst du?
Notify Rust, genau.
Eine native Implementierung einfach, um
kleine Desktop-Notifications auf Linux
loszuschicken. Da gibt es einen Standard über
Debus, der von allen Desktops unterstützt
wird. Den habe ich irgendwann mal zum Spaß implementiert.
Aber das gab es halt nur unter Linux.
Und ein Kumpel von uns,
der Felix, hat dann irgendwann mal
einen kleinen Rapper für macOS
geschrieben und das haben wir damit eingebaut.
Jetzt kann das Ding halt auch macOS-Support.
und seitdem habe ich irgendwie
innerhalb von einer Woche nochmal so 25
GitHub-Stars dazu bekommen.
Das ist jetzt mein beliebtestes
Repo auf GitHub.
Yay!
Vielen Dank. Jetzt hat es nochmal
irgendwie zwei, drei Sterne dazu bekommen, weil jemand was gebaut
hat, was es auf Mac benutzt.
Das heißt
Alarm After. Da tippst du ein
AA und dann deine Kommandozahlen-App
und dann kriegst du eine Notification,
wenn das durch ist. Beziehungsweise ich hatte es in meiner
GitHub-Timeline gesehen, weil du es gestartet hattest,
aber das habe ich in dem Moment nicht gecheckt, habe es draufgeklickt.
Das wäre ja witzig. Das wäre doch voll der gute
Anwendungsfall für Notify Rust.
Ah, der nutzt schon Notify Rust, der weiß, was geht.
Achso, das ist natürlich, dass er nochmal
Handix gestartet hat. Natürlich, dann ist ja klar,
wo das Interesse herkommt.
Naja, ich habe davon was gehört,
weil jemand anderes es gestartet hat,
der mit Notify Rust überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Aber witzigerweise hatte der dann ein Issue,
es wäre ja schön,
wenn das unter Windows gehen würde.
Und jemand anderes hatte dann
Crate vertwittert.
Ich habe hier mal mit WinRT,
das ist so ein Zplusplus-Rapper für
die Windows-Runtime, also nicht mit diesem
komischen abgespeckten Windows 10
zu verwechseln oder Windows 8 zu verwechseln.
Ich habe hier zwei Sachen, die WinRT heißen.
Ich habe hier schon mal was gemacht,
um so Dose-Notifications zu bauen.
Da habe ich mich gestern Abend nochmal hingesetzt und gedacht,
ihr könnt doch jetzt echt einfach bei euch
so ein Schimm einbauen und
mal Notify Rust für Linux und Mac benutzen
und mal WinRT. Das muss alles noch
in Notify Rust rein.
Das ist ein Zinschauer auf jeden Fall.
Also, hätte ich da irgendwie mir mal
noch mal wieder einen Windows-Rechner besorgen müssen,
oder mit dem ein bisschen kollaborieren, dass das bei mir auch
drin landet. Oh, da kann ich ja nachher noch mal
was dazu sagen zu Windows-Builds.
Erzähl. Nee, dann. Pack mal jetzt
hier gleich rein und dann gehen wir in die GitHub-Stars über.
Nee, das kommt ja dann beim nächsten
Thema. Achso, okay.
Wo machen wir denn da jetzt weiter?
Na, beim GitHub-Stars-Woche 2.
Erzähl.
Nee, bei mir? Echt?
Ja.
Also was hier gerade passiert ist, dass wir alle drei auf dieses Pad gucken und schauen, was passieren soll.
Aber wir sollten, glaube ich, einfach uns weiter unterhalten und uns nicht so fest an dieses Pad halten.
Okay, dann komme ich einfach mal zu meinen zwei Stars.
Und zwar, der erste Star wäre die Z-Share Auto Suggestions Funktion.
Wir sind beim GitHub-Star der Woche.
Ja.
Jetzt kommt das Intro.
GitHub-Star der Woche.
Dieses Soundbite werden wir zurechtschneiden, wenn wir es dann immer benutzen.
und dir.
You don't know Jack und so.
Ah, genau.
Kennt ihr das noch?
Ja, genau.
Z-Share Outer Suggestions ist ein Feature,
was Hendrik schon vorhin fast korrekt erkannt hat.
Das ist ja wie bei Fisch.
Und zwar geht es darum, wenn ich einen Befehl eintippe
auf der Kommando-Seite,
den ich in dieser Form schon mal so begonnen habe,
kriege ich in einer anderen Highlight-Farbe
den Vorschlag, willst du das nicht so vervollständigen?
Das ist ja wirklich wie bei Fisch.
Und dann drückst du einfach mal rechts und...
Das ist eigentlich so das Hauptfeature von Fisch.
Ich habe eine Kuppelfamilie benutzt Fisch
und jetzt mal, wenn ich dem über die Schulter schaue, denke ich mir,
das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Ja, das ist das geilste Feature von Fisch.
Ich hätte noch sonst noch gute Gründe, Fisch zu benutzen.
Also Fisch heißt die
Friendly Interactive Show.
Friendly Interactive Show ist eine Alternative zu Bash
und Zsch oder Zsch.
Ich habe nur den Eindruck,
dass das Feature ein bisschen sehr viel Performance
frisst, weil wenn man so ein
Base64
L-Zertifikat mal in die Kommandoteile postet,
um das irgendwo hinzuschieben, dann
dauert das irgendwie so
10 Sekunden bevor da der Filter erscheint, weil er
die gesamte Zeit guckt, ob er nicht
so einen Befehl kennt. Hast du mal geguckt, womit das implementiert
wäre? Vielleicht kann man das ja mal mit RipGrab
implementieren. Aber prinzipiell,
in meiner Sicht schon, habe ich so ein Feature drin,
dass ich einfach, also das klassische,
dass ich so eine Rückwärtssuche, wenn ich
nach oben einfach drücke und dann den
String, den ich bis dahin getippt habe, halt versucht zu finden
in meiner History. Also nicht nur am Anfang,
sondern überall in den Kommandos, die ich bisher getippt habe.
Und man dann halt so rot highlightet
und den Rest drumherum schreibt.
Genau, das ist halt geile History-Suche in Setscher.
Okay, das ist ein Standard-Feture-Wein, glaube ich.
Ich habe meine Setscher-Ausage schon so lange nicht mehr offen gehabt.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was da...
Genau, und da komme ich direkt zu meinem nächsten Star.
Die Advanced Shell History ist ein Projekt,
was das History-File durch eine
SQLite-Datenbank aussetzt.
Holy shit, möchte man das?
Ist das cool?
Ja, es ist cool, denn
man kann...
Also erstmal nutzt das System mehr Informationen.
Es speichert mehr Informationen. Es speichert nicht nur
den Befehl, sondern es speichert im Prinzip auch,
wann
der ausgeführt wurde, mit welchem Exit-Status
er zurückgekommen ist. Wenn man
einen komplexeren Befehl mit Pipes
und so ausgeführt
hat, dann auch die einzelnen
Exit-Stati der einzelnen
Befehle. Er speichert
die Sessions. Das heißt, ich kriege mit,
in welcher Abfolge ich in dem
Terminal-Fenster zum Beispiel diese Befehle eingetippt habe.
Er speichert mir mein Working-Directory.
Also ich kenne auch mit, in welchem Verzeihnis ich war.
Und das Ding
kennt auch so die SSH-Umgebungsvariablen.
Das heißt, wenn ich mich irgendwo mal einlogge,
per SSH, und mal PrintEvent oder
Export oder sowas eingebe, dann sehe ich dort ja
SSH-Connection
Informationen. Von wo
komme ich? Von wo habe ich mich eingeloggt?
Das heißt, der loggt für jeden Befehl
dein momentan das Environment?
Nein. Unglaublich kreis es an deren Database
Scheme dafür.
Nein, das ist ziemlich überschaubar.
Es gibt zwei Tabellen da drin.
und die eine
merkt sich quasi die Anzahl der Sessions
und wenn ich ein neues Tab aufmache
und diese Variable in deinem
Terminal noch nicht belegt wurde,
dann weiß diese Advanced Shell History
das ist eine neue Session, also
erzeugt der an der Datenbank einfach einen neuen Eintrag dafür
und zu dieser Session werden dann alle weiteren
Befehle angehängt.
Und das Theme dort
ist auch relativ überschaubar.
Das sind halt so die gängigen Umgebungsvariablen,
die für ein Befehl relevant sind.
Wenn du das jetzt in eine SQLite-Datenbank
hackst, dann wäre der nächste
Step, dass du einen Cloud-Dienst darin
hängst, damit du das zwischen unterschiedlichen Rechnern
synchronisieren kannst.
Wolltest du nicht mal sowas bauen?
Ja, sowas habe ich schon mal in der Macher gehabt.
Oder ich bin auch noch dran.
Und zwar ist das Advanced Chessory in C
oder Python implementiert, je weiß.
Leider funktioniert die C-Variante nicht auf Mac.
Deswegen habe ich Kian
vor zwei Wochen, glaube ich mal, genervt
zu Detailfragen zu Swift,
weil ich mir jetzt erstmal eine kleine Variante gebaut habe,
die das in Swift tut.
Und da bin ich auch direkt mal auf die Nase gefallen
mit der Event-Lube in Swift, weil
genau das Tool
macht im Prinzip quasi schon das,
das schickt den Datensatz
per REST
an den Server und
sammelt die dort und dann wurde das
Datenmodell im Prinzip um Hosts erweitert.
Und der nächste Schritt wäre
im Prinzip dann, dass man dort auch
über so eine Art Slimlane-Diagramm
sieht, wann auf welchem Rechner
welche Befehle ausgeführt wurden und ich dann
quasi nachvollziehen kann, aha, da war ich auf dem
Datenbank-Server und dort habe ich
irgendwie in dem Datenbank-Backend
irgendwas rausgesucht
und der nächste Befehle ausgeführt wurde, war aber
auf einer ganz anderen Kiste und dort habe ich irgendwas eingetragen.
Dann kann ich mir das im Nachhinein
noch so ein bisschen zusammenfusseln.
Und die und die Zeit habe ich aus Versehen die Production-Database gelöscht.
Korrekt, das wäre cool gewesen für die Kittlern-Jungs.
Ah ne, es hilft denen auch nichts.
Ist egal, aber
das ist so gerade in meiner Pipeline.
Der Typ, der das gemacht hat, wurde ja
Employee Zero oder wie?
One, oder?
Employee One genannt.
Es gab auch mal einen schönen Blogpost.
Wie geht es eigentlich, Employee One?
Das ist ein guter Blogpost.
Ja, der war schön, den habe ich auch genießen.
Dem geht es gut, der wurde nicht gefeuert.
Der wird auch nicht...
Finde ich auch nicht cool.
Nee, fehlerbasierend.
Auf dem Blog wurde sein Name trotzdem nicht einwillen.
Sein Gesicht nicht gesagt.
Wir haben ja jetzt intern sogar T-Shirts.
Employee One.
Irgendwas, was ein passendes Satz sind.
Also wenn ich glaube, wenn mir das passiert wäre,
würde ich auch nur noch mit Shit Happens T-Shirt machen.
Ja, das ist gut.
Ja.
Das ist ein cooles Projekt.
Das wäre es Tell History generell.
Ja, das ist schon horn alt.
Echt?
Ja, ich glaube, es ist sogar von Google.
Ja, die synchronisiert das zwischen allen ihren Mitarbeitern.
Ja, genau.
Nee, nee, nee, die können ja nicht synchronisieren.
Aber was die mitliefern, sind so ein paar generelle Abfragen an die Datenbank,
wo ich so mal gucken kann, was ich so eigentlich tut habe und sowas.
Was passiert dann, wenn ich mein HIST-File
ansette? Dann
loggt es trotzdem weiter? Das
hat ja im Prinzip gar keinen HIST-File.
Es ist ja die Datenbank. Ich kann sagen, wie funktioniert das?
Liest das irgendwie regelmäßig meine HIST-Datei
aus? Nee.
Das könnte man machen. Aber du ersetzt deine HIST-Datei durch
so ein FUSE-File-System?
Oh Gott, das könnte man.
Ja, das wäre richtig
creepy.
In der HIST-File kriege ich ja zum Beispiel
auch nicht mit, in welchem Verzeihung ich es bin.
Sondern das Ding
funktioniert so ein bisschen, was ich schon angedeutet habe.
Ich mache ein neues Terminal auf oder ein neues
Tab in meinem Terminal,
immer Leute oder Wahl.
Du weißt halt, in welchem Verzeichnis du bist,
anhand von den Befehlen, die du vorher gemacht hast.
Du kannst ja die gleichen Mechanismen
daraus schmeißen, mit denen du die
Spending History auf
ein Bitcoin-Wallet
schmeißt.
Weißt du das immer sicher?
Weiß ich nicht.
Verzeichnis sicher ab dem Moment, wo du
einen absoluten Pfad verwandelt hast.
Wenn ich ein neues Tab aufmache, dann steht bei mir
zum Beispiel in meiner Einstellung drin
ein neues Tab startet immer in dem
Verzeichnis, wo ich mich gerade schon mal befinde
Wenn ich ein neues Fenster aufmache
dann startet die Shell dort in meinem
Homeverzeichnis
Und ich glaube, das war es auch schon an Sonderregeln
CD- macht das schon
spieliger nachzuvollziehen
Ich habe mir so ähnliches geschrieben
die heißen CDO und CDS
also CDS Saved
und das schreibt einfach
meinen momentanen Pfad
cdo-datei und cdo
opened,
die liest einfach diesen Pfad aus.
Darf ich dir die zwei Befehle
Pop und Push, Popd und Pushd
ans Herz legen, weil genau die machen das.
Wenn du sagst, Pushd
verzeichnis, dann leg da quasi
auf einen Stack, auf einen internen Stack,
das aktuelle Verzeichnis ist und wechselt dorthin, wo du
möchtest. Wenn du sagst, Popd,
dann legst du wieder in diesen unterschiedlichen Terminals.
Nee.
Das ist quasi so ein Bookmarking.
Ich bookmarkiere mir das mit cds
und macht dann ein neues Tömmel auf und geht dann mit CDO hin.
Bis ich irgendwann mal von Kilian gezeigt bekommen habe,
dass es in Z-Shell dieses coole Z-Plugin gibt.
Z ist awesome.
Und Z, da gibst du dann einfach nur noch
einen Tile-String von irgendeinem Pfad an
und gehst dann automatisch dahin
und der bookmarkt sich das quasi automatisch
aus deiner History raus.
Auch schön.
Kommando-Zahlen-Tipps
der Woche Z.
Das Z-Shell-Plugin.
Um noch kurz auf deine Frage einzugehen,
Also dieses Advanced Shell History Plug-in-Tool funktioniert im Prinzip so,
es wird gesourcet beim Starten deiner Shell,
überschreibt ein paar, es lädt einfach ein paar Funktionen
und dann gibt es noch ein paar magische Funktionen,
die deine Shell immer ausführt, wenn du zum Beispiel den Befehl beendet hast.
Und der wird ersetzt, wenn er schon existiert,
ansonsten definiert und dieser Befehl speichert einfach den Rückgabewert
eines Befehl in diese Datenbank.
So funktioniert das und darauf kann man im Prinzip aufbauen.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch die wesentliche Magie
an diesem ganzen Projekt, denn so ein bisschen
Datenbank reinschreiben ist jetzt
eigentlich nicht der Rede wert, finde ich persönlich.
Aber wie eine Shell funktioniert
intern und was die alles so tut und treibt
und wo man an die Daten rankommt, das ist
schon wesentlich interessanter. Das wissen
heutzutage hauptsächlich nur noch Leute, die schon graue Haare
haben, schätze ich. Habe ich schon welche?
Also ich finde die Folge ernst genug.
Weitere GitHub-Stars der Woche.
Willst du weitermachen?
Ich würde weitermachen.
Für Leute, die noch mehr über solche Sachen,
wenn wir schon einmal an dem Thema drin sind, lesen wollen,
gibt es die wunderschöne Seite
Terminals are sexy.
Das ist wie so eine Awesome-Liste.
Das ist wie so eine Awesome-Liste,
eine schöne Zusammenfassung mit Sachen,
wie man sein Terminal sexier machen kann
oder was an Terminal sexy ist,
mit Links und Zubehör.
Einfach mal eine schöne Zusammenfassung,
durch die man durchblättern kann.
Damit habe ich jetzt quasi auch alles erzählt.
Das könnt ihr gerne mal in Ruhe lesen.
Ansonsten so an Tools, was ich ganz cool finde,
was ich neulich von dem gelesen habe, war
Assert CLI.
Das ist der
Blogpost oder der Twitter-Post von demjenigen,
der es gebaut hat, fasst eigentlich alles
zusammen. Ich habe hier eine kleine Kommandozeilen-App,
also eine CLI-App gebaut.
Die möchte ich aber auch testen, also habe ich mir
noch Asserts in Rust geschrieben,
mit denen ich diese Kommandozeilen-App
testen kann.
Und das ist quasi ein Testing-Framework
für Kommandozeilenanwendung.
Das ist ganz cool. Da schreibst du oben deine
Kommandozeilenanwendung rein, was du an
Parametern reingibst, so
in Chaining-Schreibweise
und dann was du
assertest, was du von der
für ein Result bekommen möchtest.
Das ist ein schönes Framework dafür.
Witzige Idee.
Und jetzt du.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich dieses Mal
drei GitHub-Stars der Woche
Deine waren sehr visual, die ich mir angeguckt habe.
Weil das eine geht sehr schnell und ich fand es witzig.
Nummer 1 ist ein
cooles Projekt, ein Deep Photo Style
Transfer. Das Ganze ist
Code und Data für
ein Paper,
was so heißt, Deep Photo
Style Transfer. Und eigentlich das
beeindruckende daran sind vor allem eben die Resultate,
die der raushaut. Der hat da einfach mal
in der Readme noch einen Stapel an
Beispielen mit drin. Da hat er jeweils ein Input-Bild,
ein Style-Bild und ein Output-Bild.
Und es ist really
fucking beeindruckend. Ein Bild von der Stadt
und ein Bild von der Stadt nachts
und schmeißt dieses Style-Bild
von der Stadt nachts
auf dieses Stadtfoto drauf
und plötzlich sieht das ursprüngliche Stadtbild
so aus, als ob die nachts wäre
und es sieht halt alles unglaublich fucking realistisch aus.
Das ist quasi das erste Bild
und dann aber nachts,
so wie das zweite Bild.
Das erste Bild ist das Input-Bild,
das zweite Bild ist das,
wo er den Stil von übernimmt
und das dritte Bild ist das,
was bei seinem Code-Bild rauskommt.
Und er hat ein Bild von der...
Das klingt nicht so beeindruckend,
wenn ich das gerade so sage,
aber der hat ein Bild von einer gelben Blume
und dann ein Bild von einer Rose als Style
und dann kloppt er das da drauf und dann hat er plötzlich das
ursprüngliche Bild, bloß halt in Rot.
Ja, was dir jetzt nicht unbedingt aufgefallen ist,
diese gelbe Blume ist einfach bloß so
an einem sonnigen Tag eine gelbe Blume und diese Rose,
da sind Wassertropfen drauf und auf dem anderen
Bild sind auch Wassertropfen drauf.
Ich finde die Übergänge unglaublich beeindruckend
von diesem Backboard.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo man das findet.
Vielleicht könnt ihr uns das in die Kommentare schreiben.
Ich habe mal sowas Geiles gesehen, da hast du
ein Foto von dir reingeschmissen, vielleicht basiert das
auf dem gleichen Ding. Du hast ein Foto von dir
reingeschmissen und dann hast du ein Bild von irgendeinem
Gemälde von irgendeinem
Künstler gehabt. Dann hast du plötzlich dein Foto
im Stil von diesem Gemälde gehabt auch.
Das heißt, ich habe ein Bild von mir
und dann habe ich ein Gemälde
von Van Gogh reingeschmissen
und dann war plötzlich das Bild von mir im Stil von Van Gogh
gemalt. So eine Stilübernahme, ja. Das ist relativ
beliebt als Projekt gerade, habe ich das Gefühl.
Aber die Results
hier fand ich besonders beeindruckend, muss ich sagen.
Ich finde das ja mit den Äpfeln lustig.
Den Äpfeln ist sehr subtil.
Ja, das ist mega.
Ich habe einfach die Farben von den Äpfeln getauscht.
Hä?
Ach so,
Input und
Style sind dasselbe Bild.
Und hinten fallen die Farben einfach durchgelegt.
Wie geil.
Ja, so ein gewisser Grad an Randomness ist dabei.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem
die Resultate, wie gesagt, beeindruckend.
Das ist mein GitHub-Star Nummer 1 gewählt.
Das sind so die Momente, wo ich mir denke,
Machine Learning wird
in spätestens 5 Jahren die Welt übernehmen.
Ja, die Singularität.
Sie wird kommen.
Ja, irgendwann.
Mein zweiter GitHub-Star der Woche ist
ein schönes Repo, was eigentlich nur Daten
für eine tolle Webseite sind.
Die Webseite ist
yourcalendricalfallacyis.com
Das musst du mir mal erklären.
Und der hat einfach eine Sammlung an Beispielen
von typischen Fallacies
halt, was ist Fallacy auf Deutsch?
Verbrechen.
A Mistaken Belief ist so die
Umschreibung, also das hast du halt eine Annahme,
eine falsche Annahme. Eine typische falsche
Annahme, was Kalenderdinger angeht.
Man hat halt einfach aufgelistet, so Dinge, die man
oftmals gerade als Programmierer
mit sich denken könnte, wenn man halt bestimmt
Dinge machen möchte.
Was Kalender angeht, ist jede Annahme.
Eben, und das ist ja gerade das Witzige an Kalenderdaten.
Das ist auch so ein Thema, von dem ich mich unglaublich gerne lese.
Und der hat halt so Dinge drin wie
Tage sind 86.400 Sekunden lang.
Das stimmt nicht. Das ist schon mal falsch.
Alleine durch die Tatsache,
dass wir Umschläge haben,
was Zeitumstellung angeht.
Wir haben aber auch Leap Seconds, die immer wieder reinkommen
und ganz vielen anderen Scheiß.
Man sollte das machen wie bei Bitcoin.
Einfach die Sekunden zählen.
Ja, vielleicht...
Es gab mal so einen Streit
zwischen Galileo, Galilee
und einem deutschen...
Papst?
Nee, Astronomen.
Kepler.
Und zwar hat der...
Das war zu Zeiten, als du Nachrichten
von anderen Leuten in Italien
aus Deutschland, wo du vielleicht fünf Wochen später
mitbekommen hast, nicht wie heute,
irgendwie schreibt jemand was.
Wenn Galileo Galileo heute leben würde, der würde seinen ganzen Scheiß
auf Hacker News schreiben.
Show Hacker News, I discovered the moods
of Saturn.
Zumindest, der hat
sich mal aufgeregt über einen deutschen
Magnus, irgendwer,
der
gemeint hatte, er hätte die gleichen Sachen
entdeckt wie er, aber drunter geschrieben
hat, dass er es zwei Tage vorher
entdeckt hat. Im Endeffekt kam aber raus,
dass die gerade in unterschiedlichen Kalender benutzt haben.
Die einen haben irgendwie schon auf den
Gregorianischen umgestiegen
und die anderen noch nicht.
Also ein paar Sachen, die mir auf dieser Website besonders gefallen sind,
sind so Sachen wie, time zones are always on the hour mark.
False. Many places have half hour offsets.
Und dann gleich danach, okay,
time zones are always on the half hour mark.
False. There are a few places that have
an offset of 15 or 45 minutes.
Fine. Time zones are
always on the quarter hour mark.
Currently true, but historically false.
Oh mein Gott, und ich wusste nicht, dass es Orte gibt,
die mehr als fünf Stunden weg von UTC sein können.
Nein, doch, tatsächlich.
13 Stunden.
14 Stunden sogar.
2006 wurde eine neue Zeitzone geschaffen.
Oh mein Gott.
Es gibt diverse Zeiten, die einfach nicht abbildbar sind.
Die letzten drei Fallacies sind
Calendrical isn't a real word.
False.
This is all really complicated.
True.
I never want to write code that handles all of this.
Wie heißt denn dieser YouTuber, der immer so ein rotes T-Shirt anhat?
Du meinst Tom Scott?
Ja, der hat auch mal ein schönes Video drüber gemacht.
Das werde ich dir auch verlinken.
Was ich ja besonders witzig fand, bei Freakshow glaube ich,
haben sie irgendwann mal erzählt, dass in BSD die Timezone Database,
also TZ Data Paket,
korrekt, komplett eingebunden wurde.
Und das ist eine deutsche Enklave
in der Schweiz gibt, die nach der
Zeit, der Berliner Zeit
quasi funktioniert, also was
Zeitumstellungen und so weiter betrifft.
So, der hat das
im Prinzip damals gesagt und hat gesagt, auf dem Linux
Distress siehst du es irgendwie nicht. Und mittlerweile
stelle ich halt fest, dass ein Ubuntu-Installer,
ein Debian-Installer, alle auf einmal
diese komische, diesen Ort dort in der
Schweiz anbieten, wenn ich sage,
hey, ich bin in Berlin, okay,
ist deine Zeitzone jetzt Deutschland
oder dieses
Mendelfing-Kanal, wie du dir sagt,
komische Otto heißt?
Es gibt Berlin-Germany und Berlin-Switzerland,
oder was?
Nee, das heißt anders,
da ist ja Stadtname dahinter.
Das ist halt etwas,
was du überhaupt nicht erkennst.
Ich habe mich immer gefragt,
warum man bei diesen ganzen Sachen,
wenn man seine Zeitzone auswählt,
immer seine Stadt auswählt.
Ich meine, Paris, Amsterdam, Berlin
haben im Endeffekt alle die gleiche Zeitzone,
aber was sich unterscheidet,
ist, wann die zwischen Sommer- und Winterzeit umschalten.
Nein, aber das ist halt auch die rechtliche Bindung an diese Sache.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt Deutschland sagt,
wir zum Beispiel Sommer- und Winterzeit,
wann die geändert wird, wir verschieben das einmal,
dann willst du natürlich auch dieses Update mit haben.
In der Hoffnung, dass das auf nationaler Ebene passiert.
Die Zeitzohnte-Datenbank wird ja regelmäßig aktualisiert.
Also wenn du mal guckst, die auf dem Jahr aktualisiert wird,
weil irgend so ein Schurkenstaat mal wieder die Meinung ist,
wir müssen die Zeit mal wieder verändern.
Das sind wir nicht im Schurkenstaat.
Also Nordkorea ist eines von diesen Ländern,
was so eine 15-Minuten-Zeitzohndifferenz hat.
Nepal auch.
Ich möchte nichts über Nepal sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, aber
ja, sie verschieben das und du willst
natürlich daran gebunden sein. Du willst jetzt nicht sagen,
hey, ich mache Amsterdamer Zeit, weil
das ja die gleiche Zeit im Moment ist.
Das kann sich auch mal ändern.
Das ist eigentlich nur der
Hintergrund der Hersteller. Eigentlich müsste man für jeden
Ort eine eigene Zeitzone haben, dass wir wieder mit diesem
Satoshi Zeitzeugen fangen. Nein, wir fangen jetzt einfach an,
alle Utilität zu nutzen, fertig, Ausschluss ist.
Das wäre gut.
Also es gibt immer diese Diskussion,
diese Sommer-Winterzeit-Umstellungen
abzuschaffen.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde die Umschaltung
zwischen Sommerzeit und Winterzeit eigentlich ganz okay.
Ich finde es schön, dass es irgendwann
im Frühling dann plötzlich
abends noch eine Stunde länger dauert.
Ja, aber es ist halt nur eine Stunde länger, weil du dich daran gewöhnt hast.
Du kannst auch einfach...
Was halt wichtig für mich wäre, dass das einfach alle Länder
gleichzeitig machen.
Ja, praktisch.
Ich finde es halt schön, dass ich alle sieben Jahre lang mal 25 Stunden
Geburtstag habe.
Im Herbst.
Du hast immer an diesem
Tages-Sommerzeit-Winterzeit-Wechsel...
Ja, ab und zu.
Wir hatten unseren Abi-Ball.
Ich hatte meinen 25. Geburtstag.
25 Stunden.
Aber der 25.
Sehr geil.
Wir hatten unseren Abi-Ball an dem Tag, wo sie gerade die
von Winterzeit auf Sommerzeit umgestellt haben.
Und es hieß, wir mussten um drei da raus sein.
Oder so.
Und wir dachten, es ist um zwei.
Bam.
Bam, war es um drei.
Ja, Pech gehabt.
Ich merke mir immer schön, wie alt du bist, weil du so alt bist
wie der CCC, der
Chaos Communication Conference.
Jetzt machst du es aber nur mal einfach,
das finde ich gar nicht gut.
Letzter Gitab-Sahle der Woche
ist ein tolles Projekt,
ein Marquis 3000.
Da hat jemand die schönen Marquis-Tags,
die wir doch alle so kennen und lieben,
die nicht offiziell erteilen
der HTML-Specs sind, in JavaScript neu implementiert
und zwar so geil, dass die auch
schräg fahren können und
rückwärts und von oben nach unten
und
ist einfach geil.
Aber schräg machst du
doch, indem du einfach
eine CSS-Transition draufschmeißt, oder?
Welcher Browser
kann denn das?
Kann man Markiere ich mittlerweile komplett mit CSS-Transitionen
bauen?
Übrigens, du solltest
vollkommen nüchtern sein, wenn du das
anguckst.
Oh Gott, das bewegt sich.
Das sieht aus wie ein Scene of Crime.
Ich finde das geil.
Ja, stimmt. Mit diesem gelben Tape,
was da einmal quer drüber geht.
Das gelbe Tape, das schräg hier durchfährt,
ist über dem blauen, aber unter dem grünen.
Es sieht einfach nur geil aus. Ja, es wirkt dolle plastisch.
Also man könnte noch so ein bisschen so einen...
Das ist wie das Cybertape
auf meinem Laptop.
Wie heißt das, wenn im Hintergrund
sich was langsamer weckt als im Vordergrund?
Mit Parallax-Effekt? Ja, genau.
Man könnte dann mit so einem Parallax-Effekt...
Mit Magik.
Ja, dann nimmst du...
Dann kannst du als Zeichen
nimmst du diese Personen-Emojis
und baume-Emojis
im Hintergrund.
Zack, kannst du eine kleine Landschaft...
Zack, hast du einen Sidesquatter-Gang.
Fantastisch.
Das wäre relativ einfach.
Nur mit Marquis-Tags und Emotis.
Ja, aber die Marquis-Tags, also die klassischen Marquis-Tags
kannst halt nicht Gefühligkeiten anpassen.
Also bei dem schon
Marquis 3000, ich glaube schon.
Ich finde,
Google hätte sein...
Du kannst nur sagen Marquis und das war's noch.
da kannst du direkt die Rute setzen.
Google hat ja Webkit nochmal
geforkt und es Blink genannt. Ich finde,
dass es besser Marquis heißen ist.
Marquis.
Marquis und Blink waren diese beiden verschrierenen Tags,
die sich dann irgendwann alle wieder abgeschafft haben.
Das ist ganz schön schlimme Sachen.
Mir freut doch Blink-Tags.
Werden die noch überall unterstützt?
Nee, warum nicht?
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Das waren halt die einzigen Möglichkeiten,
um grafische Animationen
in so ein Text-Only-Browser wie Lynx reinzukriegen.
Ach, die haben wir so unterstützt?
In Lynx? Marquis-Text?
In Marquis weiß ich nicht, aber Blink ist so die eine Sache.
Ja, da brauchst du
einen Kurses.
Nur damit es auf der anderen Person hat.
Schönen Dank, ey.
Okay, beschließen, beenden wir die GitHub-Stars damit.
Mit einem wunderschönen
Marquis 3000.
Gut, dann machen wir weiter.
Machen wir weiter. Thema 2.
Thema Steiger.
Thema früher war Herr Steiger. Hallo.
Ja, wir haben ja das letzte Mal
in der Sendung eher so zufällig
mit als Gast dabei gehabt. Dann haben wir großspurig
Werbung damit gemacht, jetzt mit Steiger.
Und dann haben wir über Twitter
die Beschwerde bekommen.
Also der Steiger ist ja ein bisschen kurz gekommen
in eurer Sendung. Jetzt redest du aber schon ziemlich aktiv mit.
Ja, ich freue mich auch so. So eine richtige Gastrolle
hast du jetzt nicht. Da bist du ja schon...
Das hat auch niemand von Gaststeiger bisher gesprochen, oder?
Übrigens, da ist das schon immer
Gastvorschein.
Hallo, hallo Henrik.
Hi, Steiger.
Hey, Kürian.
Ich habe ein Dechavü gerade.
Nein.
Ich freue mich, dass ich nochmal dabei bin.
Es macht Spaß.
Und ich kann ja
so ein bisschen über Technik-Kram
quatschen, aber mir ist ja
noch jemand in den Sinn gekommen, der eigentlich
cool in die Runde passen würde.
Fände ich. Achso.
Ja, und zwar der Jupp.
Der Jupp war übrigens derjenige, der sich beschwertet hat.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und ich könnte mir das echt sehr, sehr
ergiebig vorstellen.
Jupp hier mit wäre.
Der hat auch richtig viel Ahnung
und vielleicht
kommt er ja mal frei, kann man
vorbeikommen. Ja, schön.
Wir sollten einfach nicht zu viel über Leute reden, die gerade nicht
da sind. Vielleicht ist er bei der nächsten Folge dabei, aber jetzt
noch mal über andere Sachen. Aber an der Stelle vielleicht schön
Gruß an Jupp. Schön Gruß an Jupp.
Ich würde dir noch ein Bier übrigens
gerade.
Genau.
Ich bringe vielleicht mal so eine kleine
Auswahl an Sachen, die ich mir so
aufgeschrieben habe, weil es ja doch schon
zufried ist. Vielleicht sollten wir die nicht alle machen,
sonst ist es morgen früh noch. Ja, das ist gut.
Und zwar
fange ich mal mit dem
Face-Form der Woche.
Sorry, bevor wir jetzt spoilern,
was alles kommen könnte, du nimmst dir jetzt
eins davon. Mach ich.
Dann lassen wir es.
Ja, dann bringe ich meinen Face-Form der Woche.
Letzte Woche.
Und zwar habe ich
letzte Woche ein bisschen mit
S3, Self-House-S3-Services
rumgespielt. Bin da mal
React CS gestoßen.
Und
das ist schon ein bisschen
abgehangen, weil die können irgendwie
noch keine MSN
V4-Authentifizierung.
Das heißt, man hat ein bisschen Stress mit dem
einen oder anderen Client. Was aber geht, ist
der Transmit-Client von Panic,
den ich sehr empfehlen kann. Der ist toll.
Der ist für Mac und der ist cool.
Dieser Client hat auch
die Möglichkeit zu sagen, ich will nicht nur eine
S3-Verbindung aufbauen und dort File-Management
machen, sondern ich kann auch sagen,
mounte mir das doch mal bitte als Volume.
Dafür nutzen die Fuse.
macOS Fuse.
Und laden dazu einen Kekst, also eine
Kernel-Extension für macOS.
Und das fiel einfach um,
reagierte nicht mehr
und es passierte einfach nichts.
Da habe ich halt mal in die Konsole geguckt und da stand
auch nur Quatsch.
Warum es denn nicht geht?
Es stand aber nicht quasi
aus schließlicher Quatsch. Das hat mich zumindest
so weit unterstützt, dass ich
im Internet rausfinden konnte,
warum es nicht ging. Und das lag
daran,
dass Darwin irgendwelche
Module Slots für
Kernel Extensions hat.
Und da gibt es
genau acht Slots, die man als
nicht Apple verwenden darf,
auf seinem Rechner, um dort Kernel Extensions
zu laden. Zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte ich im Prinzip
eine Keks geladen,
um irgendwie mein iPad als
zweiten Monitor zu nutzen,
einen NTFS-Treiber,
VMware war am Start,
VirtualBox war am Start,
TuneTap war am Start für VPN.
Dann hatte ich noch Keybase
und auf einmal war schon völlig Ende.
Ich konnte einfach mal das
Views-Modul nicht laden. Nachdem ich dann VirtualBox
beendet habe und die ganzen Cacks
entladen hatte, konnte ich dann auch
meinen S3-Volume mounten mit
Transmit und das fand ich schon ziemlich
strange, was die da machen bei Apple.
Das hätten sie mal echt ein bisschen
angenehmer machen können.
Das war komisch, da so ein hartes Limit drauf zu haben.
Ja, und es ist halt irgendwo dokumentiert
und es war dann halt irgendwo bei Stack Overflow
aus Versehen dokumentiert.
So lange irgendwer mal irgendwo Bescheid.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch beknackt.
Ich glaube, das letzte Mal,
wo mir das auch viel war mit
OpenAFS, da gab es
irgendwelche Probleme mit Major und Minor Nummern
auf Linux 2.4 damals noch,
dass man dann nicht genug
Block-Devices oder sowas
verwenden konnte und dass es deswegen umgefallen ist.
Aber ich meine, da hatte
selbst Linux 2.4 vor 12 Jahren
oder so. 255
Major-Numbers für verschiedene Geräteklassen.
Und bei Mac geht
das halt irgendwie vielleicht bei 8 Geräten und danach
ist Ende. Also, falls ihr
irgendwie mal irgendeine Keks ladet
und euer MacOS der Meinung ist,
trotz Signatur und so weiter, das geht
nicht, schaut mal nach,
wie viele Keks ihr geladen habt,
die nicht auf.apple.com
.apple beginnen.
Zählt mal die Zeilen.
Es gibt bestimmt einen schönen Befehl, den kann ich auch
geben für die Shownotes.
Wenn das mehr als 18 sind, habt ihr leider Pech gehabt und solltet
irgendwas entladen.
Tatsächlich tun das auch viele Programme. Also wenn ich Keybase
beende, ist das Kekst auch entladen.
Wenn ich VMware beende, sind die
drei Keksts für VMware raus.
Aber ich habe halt
keinen Bock, alle möglichen Programme zu beenden.
Das ist ja wie bei DOS.
Ich stelle ein Gruß an
die Apple-Jungs.
Wir wollen gerade erfolgreich
mit Source vergleichen.
Genau.
den Rest nehme ich mir dann auf.
Keks, Leute.
Okay, werden wir mal ein bisschen interaktiv.
Mir ist neulich aufgefallen,
als ich ein bisschen rumgebrowsed habe,
ich bin jetzt
zufriedener
Amazon-Music-Kunde.
Warum das denn? Keine Ahnung.
Achso, weil bei mir auf Arbeit sowohl
Deezer als auch Spotify
geblockt sind.
Oh, ist ja dumm.
Ich muss jetzt nicht sagen,
wahrscheinlich ist dann morgen auch Amazon-Music-Kunde.
Keine Ahnung. Aber ist euch mal aufgefallen,
wie diese komischen Playlisten heißen?
Ich vermute, du wirst auch was Spezifisches
hinauf.
Also ich hab mich ja schon immer
ziemlich gewundert, wenn du bei Rossmann
so ein Teeregal rumguckst, was es da für komische Teesorten
gibt. Und wenn du dann mal bei Spotify
oder bei Amazon
Music anguckst, was es für
komische
Playlists gibt. Und die sind irgendwie immer
so benannt, dass die irgendwie ihr Gefühl
verkaufen müssen.
Deswegen spielen wir jetzt ein kleines Spiel.
Das Spiel heißt
T-Sorte oder Playlist
Ich sage jetzt einen Namen
und ihr sagt mir, ob das eine Playlist
auf Spotify, Amazon Music oder
Deezer ist oder ob es eine T-Sorte ist
Mal schauen, wie richtig
Okay, fangen wir mal einfach an
Sonne Afrikas
T-Sorte
Ich sage Playlist
Das ist eine T-Sorte
Ach, verdammt
Schneespaziergang
Zeit selber drüber nachzudenken.
Ich würde
nicht verstehen, wie ein Tee
schmecken sollte, der so heißt. Playlist.
Playlist.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch was mit
Zimt und Anis.
Schneespaziergang?
Es ist eine Playlist.
Magie des Orients.
Tee-Sonne.
Sehr gut. Okay, jetzt wird es
ein bisschen krasser.
Darauf ein schlecht
gesagt, bis er einfach...
Stressbuster.
Playlist?
T-Sorte. Verdammt!
Wow. Dagegen?
Nicht stressen lassen.
Playlist.
Gute Laune.
T-Sorte.
Playlist.
Beides.
Sonne.
Playlist
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr so genau
Ne, das war eine Playlist
Zuhause
Komische T-Sorte
Playlist
Träumen
T-Sorte
Winter-Indie
Indie
Playlist
Loslassen
Tesorte
Frühlingserwachen
Playlist
Köln gewinnt
Schlaflos
Playlists.
Ich geh auch auf Playlists, ja.
Das ist natürlich mein Lieblingstee bei Gshetner.
Sencha Schlaflos.
Der ist mit Guarana,
Mate und noch einmal zu kürzeln.
Sehr lecker.
Endlich Frühling.
Hatten wir schon
Playlists. Nee, Frühlingserwachen.
Ich stehe bei Amazon
Music direkt nebeneinander.
Wieder gut.
Das ist eine Tee-Solle.
Nun stehen sie mich da gerne an.
Das ist eine T-Sorte.
Und Fastenzeit.
Das wäre eine komische Playlist.
Das ist bestimmt auch eine T-Sorte.
Sehr dünne Musik, aber es ist eine
sehr dünne Musik.
Das war auch eine T-Sorte auf jeden Fall.
Aber die Überschneidungen sind irgendwie...
Es ist stark.
Schwieriger als die Gedachtheit, muss ich sagen.
Interessant, interessant.
Soviel zu unserer ersten Rubrik.
Der Hörer rät mit.
Spiel oder T- oder Playlist.
Interessant.
Ich hätte gedacht, dass die so ähnlich klingen.
Vielleicht können wir das beim nächsten Mal
irgendwie zu Grillen machen oder so.
Dann kannst du sagen, der Hörer grillt mit.
Grät mit.
Grät mit?
Nicht rät mit.
Oh Gott.
Es gab mal diesen komischen,
es gab mal so einen Koch-Podcast.
Die Leute über Essen geredet haben.
Küchenradio.
Küchenradio, genau.
Und da haben sie auch Sendungen gemacht,
Das war super fies. Ich habe mir das auch nicht lange angehört,
bevor ich da gesagt habe, nee, leck mich am Arsch.
Das Problem war, das waren mega lange Folgen.
Das waren vier Stunden oder so.
Ja, das kannst du dir, glaube ich, nicht anhören.
So viel Speicher habe ich nicht auf dem Handy.
Was?
Apropos Speicher auf dem Handy. Hast du denn seit
iOS 10.3 jetzt mehr Speicher auf dem Handy?
Also ich habe etwas mehr Speicher.
Also ich habe etwas mehr freien Speicher.
Ja, etwas mehr freien Speicher.
So ein Giga.
Aber ich kenne Leute, die haben tatsächlich 6 GB rausbekommen
mit APFS.
Ist geil. Handy.
iOS 10.3 hat in dem Minor Release
auf jedem iPhone ein neues Dateisystem installiert.
Migriert aufs neue Dateisystem.
Von HFS weg auf APFS.
Das ist wie der Switch von Windows 98 zu Windows XP
damals. Da ist das ja auch eventuell passiert.
Ich will jetzt
NTFS haben. Aber jedes iOS 10.3
Gerät läuft jetzt auf APFS
völlig neues Dateisystem.
Mit einem Update des Systems haben du
eben deine gesamte Platte
dann umformatiert?
Migriert, ja.
Das lief wohl nicht so, dass du
den Update-Prozess komplett
gekillt haben könntest, wenn du das jederzeit einfach neu startest,
sondern das hat deine Daten
auf dem Migrationsprozess
lief erstaunlich uninvasiv.
Der hat einfach
Dinge lange umhergeschieben, ohne
dass irgendwas hätte kaputt gehen können und an einer Stelle
war der kurze Switch
und da war es dann APFS plötzlich.
Und das ist effizienter,
dementsprechend haben die Leute mehr Platz auf ihrem Telefon.
Das zählt ein bisschen anders.
weshalb das jetzt nicht wirklich einen großen
anderen Effekt hat.
Das zählt ein bisschen anders.
Und der hat halt im Update-Prozess
natürlich diverse Caches gelöscht und so weiter.
Nee, also der kann...
APFS kann auch
Snapshots
und klonen und sowas.
Macht so Copy and Write oder was?
Scheint so.
Du hast Quick Copy, oder wie Apple das nennt,
dass du beim Kopieren einfach nur
einen Hardlink hast, letztendlich.
Und dementsprechend der Kopiervorgang
großen Dateien halt instant ist.
Ist das deren Alternative zu ZFS
dann? Es war lange
im Gemurmel, dass Apple auf ZFS
irgendwann umschwingt. Da gab es auch mal
bestreben zu, aber die sind irgendwann eingefroren
oder weggestorben und dann hat sich
wieder jahrelang nichts getan und dann kam
plötzlich zur letzten WWDC
2016 auch eben
APFS wurde mit announced.
Ich finde es erstaunlich, dass iOS
die erste Plattform ist, die es bekommen hat. Hätte ich
nicht erwartet. Achso, auf dem Mac gibt es noch nicht.
Nee, es ist noch nicht gut.
ist absolut plausibel, dass es die erste Plattform
ist, weil Apple komplett
die Infrastruktur kontrolliert.
Über den App Store wissen die ganz genau, was da reinläuft.
Wenn ich hier bei mir auf meinem Mac
eine Shell öffne und dort mit
Sachen mache. Und das ist auch deren Flagship-Produkt.
Das ist schon recht, ja.
Mein allerliebstes Beispiel,
oder die beiden liebsten Beispiele,
ist Steam,
die Gaming-Plattform,
also der Game Store, wenn man so will,
und die Adobe-Tools.
Die nicht klarkommen mit
Die kommen nicht nahe, wenn ich ein
Case-Sensitive-File-System habe.
Die gehen einfach mal davon aus, dass
ein Dateisystem ein großes A und ein kleines A
das gleiche ist. Das ist aber nicht so.
Wenn du das...
Bei Mac ist es so, dass normalerweise das Dateisystem
das genauso handelt und sagt,
Großschreibung ist mir egal,
die Schreibweise. Historisch bedingt.
Genau, historisch bedingt. Wenn du aber jetzt sagst,
ich will hier eher so eine
Linux-Experience mit
ordentlichen Dateien haben,
dann funktionieren diese Tools nicht.
Und es ist ein Heidenaufwand, das
richtig zum Laufen zu bekommen.
An der Stelle kann ich mir das super gut erklären,
dass die gesagt haben, hey, wir machen das auf iOS,
weil da haben wir das alles in der Hand.
Und ich glaube, selbst bei iOS-Apps gab es Probleme mit den Reinern,
so mit Unicode.
Da ist eine Versandsache dazu.
Aber auf Mac ist es halt zu krass,
die Transformation.
Ich frage mich, RPFS ist ja case-sensitive.
Was?
Achso, case-sensitive.
Ah, RFS ist case-sensitive.
Sensitive, nicht case-sensitive.
Sensitive. Es unterscheidet.
APFS ist Case Sensitive.
HFS ist Case Insensitive.
Richtig. Okay, dafür habe ich gesagt.
Aber egal. Gut.
Wenn du deine HFS-Parte formatierst, kannst du
letztendlich die Wahl treffen, ob du Case Insensitive
oder Sensitive haben möchtest. Aber
wie ich da ja schon sage,
manche Softwarepakete klappen halt einfach nicht,
wenn du ein Case Sensitive-Dateisystem hast auf dem Mac.
Was ja komisch ist. Ich frage mich aber,
was passiert, wenn irgendwann APFS rauskommt,
wenn Apple das pusht. Wenn Apple und Adobe
haben ja schon immer so eine Liebe zueinander.
Die haben ja schon
vor Urzeiten angefangen zu
komparieren. Ich glaube schon, dass die damit ein bisschen
pushen und Apple keinen Scheiß macht und
Adobe-Produkte kaputt macht. Aber bei
Werf kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass es überhaupt Bescheid ist.
Es würde ja bei den normalen Produkten schon
reichen, wenn die einfach mal die Dateinamen richtig schreiben.
Wie meinst du?
Bei Steam, bei Spielen, da steht garantiert
im Pfad ein Programm-Files für Windows
kleingeschrieben drin, weil
sich halt die Devs komplett daran
orientieren, dass das halt funktioniert.
Aber das ist halt Quatsch. Warum schreibt man das nicht richtig?
Ich meine, wenn ich jemandem einen Brief schreibe oder eine Mail, dann schreibe ich ja auch seinen Namen richtig.
E-Mail ist auch Case.
Also bei dir bin ich mir immer nicht ganz sicher, ob ich hinten das letzte E weglassen soll oder nicht.
Bei Matthias.
Bei Steiger.
Matthias.
Oh, oh, oh.
Es ist halt so eine Sache,
warum schreiben die Leute
Fader falsch, absichtlich falsch?
Keine Ahnung.
Weil sie es gewohnt sind, weil das Betriebssystem
sich eh nicht drum schert.
Hast du ein bisschen mehr
Insight in dieses Unicode-Problem mit
APFS?
Ich habe nur einen Artikel kurz gesehen
bei mir im RSS-Reader.
File-Names are just a bunch of bytes.
So will man es ja eigentlich haben.
Also macht APFS ja glaube ich nicht.
Aber die machen gar nichts.
Du kriegst halt nur den Byte-Stream.
Du kriegst halt nur Bytes.
Und dann solltest du das halt
erstmal deine Unicode-Test.
Achso, das heißt, du kannst deine Teile nur lesen,
wenn du den Coding vorher auch kennst.
Und wenn du halt weißt,
das ist ASCII, dann passt das.
Wenn du weißt, das ist US-TF8, dann passt das.
Aber du kannst den falschen Coding nicht rangehen,
weil sonst passiert nur Scheiße.
Kann man bei Apple Emojis in der Teilnahme haben?
Offensichtlich schon.
Ich könnte es maximal für HFS ausprobieren.
aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ich kann einen Dateinamen mit Emojis haben.
Ja, ich auch.
Dateinamen mit Emojis funktionieren?
Wunderbar.
Intern sieht es wahrscheinlich dann bekloppt aus.
Aber oft auf meinen Solle.
Ah ja, ist geil.
Ah, schön.
Da hat sich da ja...
HFS macht das glaube ich aber anders.
Die Normalize sind tatsächlich scheiße.
Und da passieren echt creepy...
HFS ist eh ein komisches Dateisystem in jeglicher Hinsicht.
Ja.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Frankenstein.
den sie da in die Gegenwart gezogen haben.
HFS Plus ist das ja.
HFS ist ja noch älter.
Seit wann haben sie das jetzt schon?
30 Jahre?
HFS, die haben damit angefangen, oder?
Das sind so Next-Zeiten, würde ich schätzen.
Konnten die überhaupt Ordner erstellen auf den ersten HFS?
Ich habe mal was gehört.
Da gab es sowas wie Ordner, gab es da am Anfang gar nicht.
Es war halt alles flat.
Das war halt zu den Zeiten, wo Dateisysteme noch
ja, wir müssen uns mal
gegenüber grundlegende Dinge, wie Menschen,
die Computer in den nächsten Jahrzehnten nutzen werden,
haben müssen.
Und da fällt halt alles bei rum.
Unterordner sind viel zu kompliziert
für die Menschen. Ja, aber Jahre später denkt man sich dann,
was ist das für eine dumme Idee gewesen? Aber damals war das so,
woher sollen wir es denn wissen?
Ich habe vorhin
eine schöne Notiz aus dem
CPP-Cast.
Da hat auch
jemand über, der jetzt bei
Blizzard ist, den haben sie interviewt,
da muss ich mal raus, sonst kommt in die Show,
der war
schon bei allen möglichen Game Studios.
der ist jetzt bei Blizzard, der war vorher bei EA
und die haben bei...
Der hat da so ein bisschen vom Krieg erzählt.
Und hat gemeint,
ja, es war schon schlimm, als wir
von Assembler auf C umgestiegen sind
und die Leute haben gesagt,
das kann nie so performant sein wie unser handgestreichelter
Assembler-Code und die Leute waren sehr skeptisch.
Und dann sind wir fünf Jahre später von C
auf C++ umgestiegen und die Leute haben gesagt,
das kann nie so schnell sein wie unser handgestreichelter
C-Code und die Leute waren sehr skeptisch.
Und die Coding-Conventions, die wir damals haben,
die waren auch übelst gruselig.
also alle Structs in C
mussten in einer H-Datei sein
und wir hatten keinen Version-Control
das heißt jeder hatte so seinen Playground
mein Code war in
hendrik.c
dein Code war in kilian.c
und das lag alles so nebeneinander auf einem
aber ist halt geil, dass trotzdem krasse Dinge
entstanden sind
ich hab das auch mal von der Sampler gehört
in meiner Ausbildung
da ging es mal um die Sachen
irgendeiner dieser C++ Lehrer
in der Berufsschule
einen Schwank aus seiner Jugend erzählen zu müssen
mit Assembler-Codierung und
dass da entsprechende Nob-Blasen
in dem Code waren, damit man dort
irgendwie noch Code einfügen konnte, falls du
es nicht gepackt hast, damit man die
Sprungadressen dann nicht ändern muss.
Das sind ja nicht
Zeilnummern, sondern direkt Speicheradressen.
Das ist ja nicht
Basic per se, Basic brauchtest du ja keine
hard-gecodeten Zeilnummern, aber irgendeine
andere Basic-Derivatsprache
mit Labels und sowas.
Wo du so Zeinnummern, aber du musst Zeinnummern
vergeben für jede Zeile.
Und das hast du halt Zehnersprünge gemacht,
damit du halt dazwischen noch Nummern reinschreiben kannst,
wenn du halt...
Und dann haben die explizit das freigelassen
und dann hat er gesagt, dass das mega schief
gegangen war, einer noch mal nicht da war.
Und dann hat er der nächste weitergeschrieben
und da waren irgendwie so fünf oder
sechs Nobs und der Typ, der
krank wurde, der wusste aber,
dass an dieser Stelle noch irgendwas
rein musste. Und der andere,
der ihn vertreten hat, wusste das eben nicht
und hat halt einfach dort diese Blase ausgebaut
und hat dann noch irgendwelches Zeug dort reingeschrieben,
irgendwelche Programmcodes und dann kam er wieder und so,
ah, wir haben doch hier noch irgendwie was offen,
das muss doch rein, da muss auch ein Core rein.
Es gibt Leute,
die jahrelang so gearbeitet haben
und die haben halt damit gearbeitet
und keiner hat sich gedacht, das ist doch eine scheiß Idee,
das müssen wir aber anders machen.
Das ging einfach jahrelang so weiter. Also eine noch Geschichte,
die dir noch erzählt hatte, war, es hieß
Swing Commander und die hatten ein Problem,
wenn du das Programm beendet hast,
dann ist es abgeschmiert
und dann gab es immer eine Speicherverletzung
oder Stackfault oder irgendeine
hast du vom Betriebssystem so eine Fehlermeldung bekommen
und das haben sie auch nicht gefickt gekriegt
stattdessen haben sie halt auf der Stelle auf dem Stack
eine kleine Meldung gelegt
das ist halt irgendwie das Programm geschlossen
das ist abgeschmiert und hat es als Fehlermeldung
quasi dann dargestellt
Thank you for playing Winkommar
Ja, echt
Ich hab mich manchmal auch gewundert
auf DOS irgendwelche alten Spiele
gestartet und dann kam dann halt immer so ein
vielen Dank, dass du das gespielt hast, so eine Meldung.
Da dachte ich mir, was, es ist ja nett und so.
Aber hey,
also
creepy walkaround.
An der Stelle packen wir aber auch nochmal zu deinen
Sender späßen gerade den Link
in die Show Notes von wegen dieser wunderschönen
alten Story, Melden the Proof of
Compilers, von so einem alten
Coder, der noch
vor Compiler-Zeiten gelebt hat
und in einer Zeit, wo
andere Leute in kompilierten Sprachen geschrieben
er halt einfach der Meinung war, sowas braucht man nicht.
Und hat halt seine handgestreichelte
Sembla geschrieben und er hat das gut gemacht
und andere hatten keine Ahnung, was er getan hat.
Im Endeffekt kommt immer noch eine Abstraktionsstufe
oben drauf und die Leute denken sich,
wozu bräuchten das jetzt? Und wenn man nimmt es an,
dann ist es halt das Normale.
Nehmen wir Zeiten von Electron Apps und JavaScript,
dann können wir holen.
Und wenn ich mir das überlege,
C ist ja auch noch nicht wirklich schnell.
Also was schnell ist,
ich muss das mal anders aufziehen.
Der springende Punkt ist, wenn jemand sagt,
mein Code soll schnell sein
und dann will er mit C arbeiten, dann finde ich
das ist halt ein bisschen verfehlt, weil
schnell brauche ich ja wirklich nur, wenn ich
Takte zähle, wenn ich wirklich richtig viel
Progress
machen muss, viel berechnen
also Supercomputing
Schnell brauchst du auch, wenn
es für deinen Benutzer einfach bloß nicht schmerzhaft anfühlen
Der Punkt ist, wenn
ein normaler Typ am Rechner sitzt
also ein Benutzer
dann hast du dort immer so ein
gemischtes Loadpattern
Berechnungen und I.O.
Wenn du Supercomputering machst,
dann hast du im Prinzip Rechnen.
Da ist das gesamte
I.O. Zeug eigentlich, wenn es geht, abgefrühstückt.
Es sei denn, du machst irgendwelche Späße
und tracest deine Anwendung oder so.
Du musst halt Daten rausschreiben.
Aber wenn du rechnest, rechnest du.
Und in dem Moment ist Fortran
deutlich schneller.
Das, was man mitbekommt,
ist so handgestreichelt
der Asample-Code,
kommst du auf fast 100%
der Leistung. Also 99,
ist es sehr nah dran.
Da musst du wirklich
viel streicheln.
Auf dem Skillset, was du halt empfindest.
Und mit Fortran kommst du
immer noch leichter,
deutlich näher an das Maximum ran,
als mit C. Weil Fortran einfach
dafür ausgelegt ist.
Wenn du jetzt linear Algebra machst.
Zum Beispiel.
Aber das ist ja häufig, dass du das bei
SoCompuling gemacht hast.
Deswegen hast du ja in Mathematik-Libraries,
in Python, in NumPy oder SciPy
sowas wie Blas drin.
Blas ist Basic Linear Unreper
Systems. Das ist eine Kategorie
von Systemen. Und das ist aber
eine
Fortran-Bibliothek, die
1975 angefangen wurde.
Die hast du heute noch, die wird mit Python
noch mit ausgeliefert. Und es wird ab und zu
wird mal
die GCC-Toolchain
angepasst.
Da wird es noch weiter
gepflegt. Aber es ist hauptsächlich
solche Libraries. Aber Blast-Libraries
sind eigentlich eine ganze Klasse
an Libraries, die man da
nutzen kann. Und da gibt es auch
verschiedene Varianten. Da gibt es auch teilweise
von den Herstellern optimierte Varianten. Also von Intel
kriegst du zum Beispiel eine Blast-Library,
die ist optimiert auf die Endel-Prozessoren und die
ist dort richtig schnell.
Zum Beispiel.
Da hast du jetzt so eine Hochsprache wie C,
keine Schocks.
Wenn du drüber nachdenkst, ist ja
ist ja C auch nur
so ein CoffeeScript für Assembler.
Das sollten wir eigentlich
zu dem folgenden Titel heute machen.
C, das CoffeeScript für Assembler.
Naja, das hatte neulich der
eine CppCast-Typ
auf Twitter auch geschrieben.
Also meine
Funktionssignaturen in C++ sehen mittlerweile
so aus und da stand da halt
Const
Value, Const Name,
ConstExper
und dann zum Schluss noch NoExcept, weil du explizit
C++ ranschreiben sollst, dass du das Ding
keine Exception schmeißt. Und da ist einfach so
viel Ceremony dabei,
weil die einfach jedes Default in ihrem
Standard falsch machen, sodass du immer mehr schreiben
musst, dass ich dann einfach mal unten drunter geschrieben habe.
Eigentlich bräuchte man für C++ mittlerweile eine
Compile-To-Sprache.
Ja, aber
die ganzen Sane-Defaults, die musst du alle händisch machen.
Ja. Aber übrigens
bei diesen ganzen Compile-To
so und so, und hatten wir
vorhin auch,
wenn du jemandem deinen Startup pitchen möchtest
oder irgendwie dein Produkt erklären möchtest,
sagst du immer, das ist das und das, was man schon kennt,
für das und das anderer Use Case.
Sowas wie,
was war mal diese kontroverse Bude?
Yelp für Menschen
oder sowas.
Wo du deine Freunde bewerten konntest
mit wie freundlich sind sie und wie cool sind sie
und sowas.
Das ist nie gelauncht worden.
Aber jedes Mal, wenn dir einer was erklärt,
sagst du, das ist GitHub für Gärtner
oder sowas.
Über für Pizza.
Facebook für Tiere.
Das habe ich neulich gelesen.
MongoDB ist Snapchat
für Datenbanken.
Schön.
Ja, da kann man schon ganz schön
vor die Wand rennen.
Was ist eigentlich am MongoDB so schlimm?
Es hat witzige
Sicherheitslücken, weil es irgendwie mit
Standardeinstellungen, die die meisten Leute
nicht annehmen, weil mal das war, Redis.
Ja, das drückt
wahrscheinlich genauso.
Ich denke wahrscheinlich nichts Falsches hier.
Wie hieß dieses verteilte
Diaspora, dieses verteilte soziale Netzwerk?
Die haben angefangen mit CouchDB,
was ja auch so ein... Das ist ja viel zu modern.
Was? Nee.
Das hätte ich Diaspora nicht zugetraut. Doch, doch, doch.
Die haben mit einem Document Store
angefangen, weil die gedacht haben, hey, cool und bla,
und wir können ja Schema, das
den ganzen Käse irgendwie speichern.
Und dann hatten die richtig viel
Stress, nachdem sie festgestellt
haben, dass CouchDB eine echt blöde Idee
ist, um verteilte Daten zu speichern,
Weil niemand genau weiß, welche Version ist denn jetzt richtig.
Da hatten die echt viel Stress und haben das irgendwie händisch zu 80% migrieren müssen,
was da in diesem gesamten Internet rumflog.
Weil die einfach nicht mehr mitbekommen haben, welche Daten sind denn die richtigen
und was ist irgendwie eine Kopie und was ist jetzt der aktuelle Stand und was ist der falsche Stand.
Gerade für so ein Fed-Arach-System ist es ja sehr praktisch.
Richtig.
Und dann kam irgendwie so raus,
was war der ursprüngliche Denkfehler an diesem Prozess
oder an der Planung.
Und zwar sind solche Sachen eigentlich nur Caches.
Also ein Document Store ist eigentlich nur ein Cache.
Das ist nur eine kondensierte Variante von strukturierten Daten,
die du zusammenfasst, wo du sagst,
ich habe ja schon mal den Select gemacht,
auf Deutsch gesagt.
Genau deswegen hast du bei Facebook zum Beispiel auch mehrere Realitäten,
Dass sie sagen, okay, du hast zwar verschiedene Datenbanken,
aber es ist eingeplant, dass die nicht synchron laufen,
dass die nicht konsistent gegeneinander sind.
Sondern es gibt dann Abgleichpunkte, wo das angeglichen wird.
Da kriege ich das mit.
Aber es ist halt nicht beabsichtigt.
Das schaffst du ja auch gar nicht teilweise.
Wenn du so ein unglaublich großes System hast,
mit so vielen Datenmengen,
dass du sagen kannst, ich kann das nicht konsistent halten in sich komplett.
Es gibt keine einzelne Realität.
Das ist wie Google Files.
Dann will ich eigentlich viele Realitäten haben,
die ich aber im Nachhinein auch irgendwie abgleichen kann.
Wo ich zumindest sage, es gab mal in der Vergangenheit
einen Punkt, wo die gleich sind.
Das ist spannend.
Und bei Diaspora sind wir da richtig
gegen die Bank gerannt.
Wir sind bei über zwei Stunden.
Wir sollten, glaube ich, langsam mal zum Ende kommen hier.
Bevor wir hier
weiterhin über fastfaktische Datenbanken reden?
Ja.
Das wäre eigentlich cool.
Du hast eine Datenbank und dann hast du
alternative Daten.
Und Fake-Daten.
Fake-Daten.
Und dann machst du eine Anfrage
und dann weißt du nicht genau, was du rauskriegst.
Ja, aber es ist alternativ.
Ich habe gerade mal
deine Aussage mit
C is basically just a coffee script for a simpler
auf Englisch getweetet.
Das habe ich schon mal getweetet, glaube ich.
Und erste Antwort mit
a leaky and horrible abstraction
on top of it.
Schön.
Hey, Kolja, falls du das hörst.
Danke für die Antwort.
Real-Time-Follower.
Ich glaube, wir beenden diese Folge langsam mal.
Kommt zum Ende.
Es hat auf jeden Fall viel Spaß gemacht.
Das war akronomisierbar Folge 3.
Ja, Folge 3.
Vielen Dank.
Krasser Scheiß.
Zum ersten Mal mit einem Vollzeitsteiger.
Vollzeitsteiger.
Damit du mitgeredet hast.
I think that you said that at the beginning of the date, because then the Diff is,
until I finished with the cut, really good.
There are podcasts that say, on the day and the day are on, on the day they want to release it.
Yes, but look at the next week.
We don t have a lot of fun.
Yes, but then I must just do it.
I'm going to do it.
And until you heard it, you're going back to three days.
Ach, ich glaube,
hier sind nicht viele Sachen dabei, die ich
prüfen muss. Also normalerweise ist unser Prozess,
wir nehmen es auf,
Kylian schneidet es.
Bislang war nicht viel zu schneiden.
Und ich höre es da nochmal durch,
aber ich habe eigentlich noch weniger
Zeit, das nochmal komplett durchzuhören.
Ich habe eigentlich gerade in unserem Pad geschrieben,
das wäre was für
Off-Air,
aber eigentlich können wir es auch, es ist eigentlich mal interessant,
das Thema, wir interessieren,
wie andere Podcaster das machen.
Zum Durchhören, du hast es ja einmal dann bearbeitet,
du hast Chapter Max gesetzt und dann schickst du mir einen Link zu einer Datei,
die ich dann runterlade und mit irgendeinem Tool VLC auf dem Handy oder sowas anhöre,
was dann von vorne anfängt, wenn ich es mal irgendwie geradeaus versehen zumache.
Die stört, dass du es in der Podcast-Teile nicht drin hast.
Und ich hätte gerne so eine Art Beta-Feed.
Das wäre cool.
Das wäre dann für unsere Premium-Abonnenten.
Das wäre cool, genau.
Das wäre dann pre-released Content für unsere...
Haben wir eigentlich sowas wie Patreon oder sowas?
Das wäre aber witzig.
Ja, lass mal aufsetzen. Aber wir könnten bei GitHub zum Beispiel sowas...
Vielleicht könnten wir anfangen, uns überhaupt
mal eine Webseite zu bauen.
Ja, das braucht nicht mal eine Webseite.
Das ist ein bisschen ab, dass wir noch keine haben.
Gut.
Danke fürs Zuhören.
Auf jeden Fall. Und ich würde sagen, bis zur nächsten Folge.
Genau.
An dieser Stelle geht der nächste Podcast weiter.
Ciao, macht's gut.